Sollte jetzt wieder gehen.
Hoffentlich haben wir noch Quality Options.
Ja, wir haben auch noch Quality Options, alles gut, sehr nice.
Funktioniert wieder.
Sag mal, kennt sich jemand von euch aus mit Audio Einstellungen, wie man Kompressor und
Noise Gates ordentlich einrichtet.
Ich hab jetzt zwar da ein paar Tutorials gelesen und blicke so ungefähr durch, was da wie
welches Setting macht, aber so wirklich ist das nicht meine Welt.
Checkt das, checkt das jemand, also soweit ich weiß, ist das gut, Noise Gate ist glaube
ich relativ einfach, alles was irgendwie unter einem gewissen Level ist, macht er das Mikrofon
aus und er macht es wieder ein, wenn es über einem gewissen Level ist, das ist sowas wie
Push to Talk im Endeffekt in Discord und das hier ist irgendwie die Zeit, wie lang mal
über diesem Schwellwert sein muss, das hab ich gecheckt, das krieg ich noch gebacken.
Na guck, jetzt macht er, ich glaub das ist schon an, wenn ich das jetzt ausschalte, guck
da geht das Mikro nie ganz aus.
Wenn ich es einschalte, dann gehts unter einem gewissen Schwellwert, gehts aus, zack, aber
das genau funktioniert ist mir nicht klar, also das ist ok, aber was stell ich beim Kompressor
jetzt ein?
Mein Kompressor ist ja dafür da, dass es quasi, dass wenn es übersteuert, dass euch
nicht die Ohren wegfliegen und dass wenn ich zu sehr flüstere, dass es nicht zu leise
ist.
Wenn ich das richtig, richtig, aber ich mach das jetzt mal wieder aus, weil ich blicke
da nicht durch, ich muss mir das erstmal nur angucken.
So, also was war mal heute, ich hab's ja schon vor der Weile erzählt, ich hab mir ein bisschen
neue Hardware gekauft, warum ist jetzt mein OBS ausgegangen?
Ich muss mal kurz mein Browser reloaden, ich glaube da ist es abgekackt, ja wunderbar,
nämlich der Stream geht noch, hätt mich auch gewundert, wenn nicht, lull.
Gut, also was wir heute machen, ich hab jetzt schon vor der Weile erzählt, ich hab mir
neue Hardware geholt, ihr kennt ja noch das alte Video wahrscheinlich, das da, das da,
das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich noch, ne Moment, das ist das ganz alte, das da, das da, das
kennt ihr wahrscheinlich noch.
Also aktuell ist es ja so, dass ich hier oben die fette 4HE Kiste drinne hab und mein Problem
ist, also an sich funktioniert das wunderbar, ne, die Kiste haut Performance-mäßig alles
weg, was ist was man sonst so im Heimgebrauch an Säubern da irgendwie am Start hat, also
da muss man sich keine Gedanken drum machen, das Problem ist bloß, dass diese Kiste so
ziemlich alles bei mir macht, also die da, ne, die man hier jetzt krass aufgeschraubt
sieht, die macht bei mir alles, die macht ZFS-Rate mit 3x10TB Platten, die macht Internet-Router,
die macht Fernseh-Gedöns inklusive Aufnahme, Live-TV, sonst was, Coding-Gedöns, Transcoding-Gedöns,
Home-Assistent-Gedöns, Next-Cloud-Gedöns, File-Server-Gedöns, die macht alles, ich
muss es jetzt nicht weiter ausführen glaube ich, die macht alles und das Problem dabei
ist so ein bisschen, dass wenn ich die Kiste neu starten muss, dass hier bei mir im Haus
nichts mehr funktioniert, die macht einfach alles, so schön das ist, dass man hier ein
bisschen was mit Power hat, erstens, habe ich die Power nie in der Art und weil man beacht
übrigens hier mal die tolle PC-Express-Karte falsch rum, ich habe die Power nie gebraucht
und Experimente, die ich da machen wollte mit Grafikkarten, Pass-Through und Gedöns
und so habe ich ein bisschen gebastelt, hat eigentlich auch ganz gut funktioniert, brauche
ich aber nicht, deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich mach das anders, die Kiste behalte ich
natürlich, aber ich hebe mir die Kiste auf für Testzwecke, das heißt wenn ich damit
was basteln will, habe ich immer eine Kiste, die kann ich hochfahren, aber ansonsten bleibt
die aus und das wird jetzt ersetzt durch einen Mikrotik-Router, also sprich das Internet-Gedöns,
was hier drüber läuft, ich habe ja einen Unity-Media-Anschluss und einen Telekom-Anschluss,
den werde ich kündigen dieses Jahr und den Unity-Media umstellen auf 400 runter und 40
ab, das haben die ja schon auf Twitter damals geschrieben, dass das kein Problem ist und
da kommt Telekom weg, aber aktuell sind es zwei Internet-Anschlüsse, verschiedene WLANs
und WLANs, habe ich auch zwei Stück, offen, Exitpoint steht unten im Wohnzimmer, das
was hier neben dran hängt ist, der hängt immer noch da, aber da macht nichts mehr,
da steht auch, stimmt gar nicht, hängt gar nicht mehr da, der Billig-TP-Ling-Access-Point,
der liegt hier in der Kiste, damals, wie gesagt, das Ding macht alles so und die Internet-Geschichte,
Netzwerk-Geschichte, die das macht, wird ersetzt durch einen Mikrotik-Router mit 5 Ports, das
reicht, weil hier sind ja noch Switche dran, steck mal Böller rein, wo soll ich denn Böller
reinstecken, außerdem ist das nicht der 31., findest du irgendwas, was 1200 Euro gekostet
hat, Böller reinstecken, ich glaube, mit Wechsellaufwerken, nee, viel mehr, mit Platten,
mit Platten viel mehr, allein schon so eine 10T-Platte hat ja schon 400 Euro gekostet,
nein, allein schon die Festplatten haben 1200 Euro gekostet, das Ding hat locker 2,5K gekostet
insgesamt, ganz bestimmt stecke ich da Böller rein, 1500 Euro Switch unten drunter, 10G,
hier, da, 10G-Switch, übelst nice, brauch ich aber auch nicht, naja, wie dem auch sei,
hier, Switch, wie dem auch sei, ich werde das jetzt ersetzen durch einen 5-Port-Mikrotik-Router,
der macht dann Internet, die VLANs fürs, für einem Automatisierung und Gedöns, hat alles
netzwerkmäßige, wird also einmal Mikrotik-Router, dann eine Kiste, die wir heute installieren
werden, was heißt, eine Kiste, aktuell ist es eigentlich nur ein Board mit einem RAM-Riegel
drauf und liegt hier neben mir, so viel ist das ja nicht, das ist eine 2-Kern oder 4-Kern
Celeron Billig-Kiste, aber für ein bisschen Home Assistant und wie gesagt, ich brauche
ja keine Leistung, das Ding eilt sich den Hintergrund, das macht nichts, ja, und das
kommt dann quasi, das ist quasi die Heimautomatisierungskiste, die hängt dann auch quasi im gleichen VLAN
wie alle WLAN Heimautomatisierungen, das klingt jetzt bescheuert, der ist im gleichen VLAN
wie das WLAN, aber ist halt so, kommt das rein, also sprich, da kommt Heimautomatisierungszeug
drauf, vielleicht das Fernsehzeug, da muss ich mal gucken, ich gucke ja nicht viel Fernseh,
da kommt der Nginx Reverse-Boxy drauf, da kommt, ja, muss ich mal gucken, also alles,
was quasi nicht ins interne Netzwerk gesurft wird, kommt dann da drauf und dann habe ich
noch eine Mini, so ein Single-Board-Computer mit Zata, wo einfach dann eine 10TB Festplatte
dran kommt und die zweite kommt per USB dran und wird einfach nachts gestartet, wird drauf
geersyncht, scheiß drauf, einfaches Setup schlägt im Prinzip kompliziertes Setup, zwar
nicht von der Performance her, aber das kann einfach weniger kaputt gehen, ZFS, ZFS-Rate,
ZFS-Rate, was ist das, ZFS-Rate 1, ist das glaube ich, also Rate 5, ZFS ist geil, ZFS
ist geil, frisst halt RAM ohne Ende, die Sache ist, ich benutze davon im Endeffekt ja auch
fast nichts an geilen Features, ja, ich repliziere nix, ich mache kaum Snapshots, das ist einfach
nur da, um da zu sein, deswegen wird das jetzt relativ rudimentär und billig, wieder eine
Platte auf das interne Nass, X4 drauf, zweite 10T-Platte an USB dran, einmal in der Nacht
wird gesyncht, Airclone, sonst war es vielleicht noch Cloud-technisch und dann ist Ruhe, aus
ist.
Alles sind VMs oder sogar Docker, also aktuell habe ich so ziemlich alles an Virtualisierungsgedöns
am Start, was es irgendwie gibt, außer Hyper-V, ich habe hier auf dem Desktop, habe ich
hier auf dem Workstation, auf dem Server habe ich ein paar KVM, KVM-Kisten drauf, kann ich
euch mal zeigen, kann ich euch mal zeigen, ja, da laufen aktuell KVM-VMs drauf, ich hoffe
man sieht, ja, das sieht man, ich sehe es in der Vorschau, das sind meine KVM-VMs, dann
habe ich auf dem Server selbst, 2.100, auf dem Server selbst, das ist wahnsinnig aktuell,
habe ich schon eben, habe ich schon einmal aktualisiert, läuft, also das ist jetzt meine
fette, meine fette 4HE-Kiste, äh, ja doch, meine fette 4HE-Kiste, auf dem Server selbst
laufen dann jede Menge LXC-Container, das sind, die haben tolle Namen, wo wir gerade
dabei sind, ich habe die Twitch-Emotes genommen, die finde ich am besten zur Funktion vom jeweiligen
Server passen, also sprich Dance Game ist gegen Werbung, Eli Giggle ist, warum auch immer,
ich weiß nicht, was ich mir dabei gedacht habe, das Emote verwendet keine Sauber eigentlich
heute, ist der Fileserver und Backup, Failfish, weil es immer rum buggt, ist der Netzwerk
installen Server, Giftplitz, weil man halt Zeugs drauf schiebt, ist Nextcloud, Gebaited
ist, ja, war ich mir zu fein, die muss wahrscheinlich Gebaited heißen, weil sie keine Beschreibung
hat, ich weiß es nicht mehr, was Gebaited war, ja anscheinend auch wichtig, weil sie
läuft, ja, Gebaited, Vohio ist einmal Mail-Backup-Zeugs von Google, GMX und Gedöns, das sind
entsprechende Namen, das schiebt Kontaktdaten zur Fritzbox, weil die Fritzbox in das Fritz-Phone
natürlich kein offenen Standard wie CalDAF oder so kann, das muss der immer in das eine
Fritzbox-Format umwandeln und Comanbra ist TV-Server, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung,
was Gebaited ist, ich glaube der DNS, nee, der DNS ist schon hier oben, ich weiß nicht,
was Gebaited ist, kann schon mal, wofür brauchst du einen PXE-Server zu Hause, ja haben, hat
keinen tieferen Sinn, wahrscheinlich einfach, der ist ja auch aus, wie du siehst, wahrscheinlich
einfach, ach nee, ich weiß noch, wozu, zu Windows installieren, das war zu Windows installieren,
weil ich nie Windows USB-Sticks am Start habe, habe ich mal eingerichtet, dass man Windows
über, wie ist das, Windows PE oder so, Boot installieren kann, das heißt, wenn ich hier
mal Windows installieren muss, weil einer meiner Dinger mit Windows drauf kaputt ist,
kann ich das da, ja oder ich könnte auch, ich könnte auch simple Netboot drüber machen
und so, aber wahrscheinlich funktioniert es gar nicht, weil das hatte ich schon ewig,
mal hier, last used add, das ist uralt, das ist einfach, nee, einfach da, das verwendet
ich im Prinzip, eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht, ja, Moment, last used ergibt keinen
Sinn, state running, last used add, kann das sein, dass der einfach schon so lange runnt,
ich gehe mal davon aus, was haben wir denn für einen Moment, muss mal gucken, so allzu
lange uptime können wir eigentlich gar nicht haben, naja, okay, läuft schon ein bisschen,
ich bilde mir ein, ich habe ihn erst neu gestartet, aber anscheinend doch nicht, läuft schon
ein bisschen, ja, schafft der normale Windows Desktop Rechner nicht unbedingt, aber weil
ich den einfach neu booten muss wegen Updates, hätt ich Updates gemacht hier mal, irgendwann,
dann hätte ich auch nicht so viel uptime, 291 Tage, schon ordentlich, genau, und ja,
und dann habe ich auch noch ein paar Docker-VMs, wo wir noch dabei sind, oder Docker-Container,
wir haben ja hier die Heimautomatisierungs-VM, ich sage ja aktuell ist das Ding ein großer
Single Point of Failure, das Server, obwohl das ist meine Heimautomatisierungs-VM und wenn
man da drauf guckt, das ist die da, die, da mache ich regelmäßig Updates, so, da läuft
auch noch eine Docker drauf, also ich hab viel zu viel Wildwuchs im Endeffekt, ja, da läuft
alles mögliche drauf, das ist, das ist viel, das ist total wirr, ja, das ist, das ist im
Endeffekt glücklich. Ihr müsstet erstmal die Netzwerksetting sehen dazu, die kann
ich euch jetzt aber nicht zeigen, ich habe in meiner, meiner pfsense firewall-vm habe
ich irgendwie, 6 oder 7 Interfaces, das reicht ja auch für jedes VLAN, noch ein extra Interface,
Es ist auch übertrieben kompliziert. Das heißt, wie gesagt, das Ding ist ein riesiger Single-Point-of-Failure.
Warum nicht alles unter Docker? Weil ich der Meinung bin, wenn man Docker ordentlich macht, dann macht man sich eigene Container.
Weil eines der schönen Sachen von Self-Hosted ist ja, dass man weiß, was man laufen hat, was du bei
installieren blind von Docker Hub jetzt nur auch wieder nicht hast. Ja, und wenn du ein bisschen standardabweichende Sachen machen willst,
dann fährst du einfach mit einem System, was du ändern kannst im Betrieb besser als mit Docker.
Das ist einfach die Frage, was man braucht. Zum Beispiel diese Home Assistant-Geschichte ist als Docker wunderbar.
Da ist es nämlich wurscht, was drunter ist. Da sage ich einfach hier Home Assistant Start, paar Addons, gut ist.
Für meine ganzen LXC-Kisten, da will ich ja selbst was drauf machen. Ich will auch mal per Kommandozeile auf die TV-Server drauf
und da ein bisschen rumbasteln und so was. LXC ist halt einfach mehr ein komplettes System, wohingegen Docker eine einzelne Anwendung ist.
Das ist halt immer die Frage, was man braucht. Das hat beides eine Daseinsberechtigung. Und deswegen habe ich halt auch alles.
Und alles ist mir einfach zu kompliziert. Das ist zwar architektonisch, also von der Architektur her, ist das alles ganz nice.
Und das ist im Prinzip auch das richtige Tool für den richtigen Zweck. Aber es ist einfach unnötig daheim.
Das ist komplett overkill. Deswegen bin ich mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob ich auf die Kisten, die wir heute installieren,
überhaupt die Home Assistant-Docker-Installation drauf mache oder nicht einfach direkt Python, Virtual Env und drauf gehauen.
Was benutzt du für eine Distro, WM und Shell? Also das hier ist, und das benutze ich auf der Arbeit auch,
also das ist im Prinzip das, was ich benutze, ist I3 als Window-Manager Distro, WM und Shell.
Also wie gesagt, Distro ist Manjaro. Das ist eine Archlinux-Variante. Window-Manager ist I3 auf Xorg.
Who cares, Wayland. Und Shell, das ist ZSH mit TMAX im GNOME-Terminal.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, ich habe jetzt ja die Hardware hier schon eine Weile rumliegen. Ich muss selbst mal nachgucken,
was das jetzt eigentlich für ein Board genau ist, was ich mir da geholt habe.
Ich habe nämlich wirklich irgendwas sehr Energiesparendes gesucht.
Und ich muss mal kurz drauf gucken, ob man irgendwo erkennt, was das für ein Board ist.
Aha, hier SROCKJ. Das ist nix Dolles. Ja, das da.
Aber für Heimautomatisierungszeug ist es deutlich, deutlich angenehmer als Raspberry Pi.
Raspberry Pi ist einfach langsam, wenn du da Home Assistant mit einer gewissen Menge draufmachst.
Wenn du das Ding mal neu starten musst, warte ja gefühlt fünf Minuten.
Was hat das Grill zum Geschenk gesagt? Noch nix. Das hat es nämlich noch gar nicht.
Genau, dieses Ding da habe ich mir geholt für Ablösung für mein Heimautomatisierungszeug.
Ah ja, okay, es ist nicht nur ein Dual-Core, es ist sogar ein Quad-Core, Zeleron, irgendwas.
Und ich habe das einfach genommen, weil es das billigste Board war und das stromsparendste Board,
was PCI Express hat, sogar zwei oder? Nee, eins. Das andere ist eine Spiegelung unten drunter.
Hat das eins oder zwei? Eins. Was ein PCI Express hatte.
Und das war wichtig, weil ich eine TV-Karte drauf haben möchte mit Quad-Tuner und das Ding ist halt PCI Express.
Fertig, billigste Board ever, kostet auch nix im Endeffekt.
Was kostet denn das? Ja, jetzt kriegst du irgendwie...
Wahrscheinlich, wenn du ein bisschen suchst, kriegst du für 70 Euro oder so.
Also absolut kein Vergleich zu hier 2,5K-Kiste, ist natürlich auch ein Witz von der Leistung her dagegen.
Und das installieren wir heute und richten ein paar Sachen drauf ein.
Und vor allem, ich wollte heute halt mal auch streamen, weil heute sind halt viele Leute auch daheim
und das wäre jetzt irgendwie auch ein bisschen blöd, wenn ich heute nicht mal den Stream anwerfen würde.
Und ich muss auch ein bisschen was machen, wo wir einfach ein bisschen labern können
und wo ich mich nicht so sehr wie bei Progas konzentrieren muss.
Ja, und das Ding ist halt... Jetzt kannst du mal Makros mal verwenden.
Das Ding ist halt wirklich stromsparend und im Prinzip ist es crap.
Aber für so ein bisschen 24-7, das läuft halt 24-7 und ein bisschen Heimautomatisierungszeug, Fernsehaufnehmen,
Kram und ein bisschen Kleinkram, ist das vollkommen ausreichend.
Da wird einmal nachts ein Backup von gezogen, wenn es verreckt, verreckt es halt.
So what? Dann geht es halt mal einen halben Tag nicht oder einen Tag, bis ich bei Amazon was Neues bestellt habe.
Das ist... Im Prinzip ist die 4HE Kriste Overkill und zu viel auf einer Sache drauf.
Also das ist echt ein Problem.
So, ich hoffe jetzt mal das funktioniert, weil ich habe das jetzt so gemacht.
Ich habe hier einen... Ist das überhaupt die läuteste OBS-Version?
Anscheinend.
Äh, ich habe hier mal meine Elgato angeschlossen und wir schalten jetzt mal das Ding ein und gucken.
Ah, wir schalten... Nee, vorher müssen wir nochmal Ubuntu downloaden.
Ich bin ein... Bei mir ist es... Ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt. Ich finde es eigentlich lustig, ne?
Meistens Leute sagen ja Ubuntu so auf dem Desktop und auf dem Server dann irgendwie, was weiß ich,
Debian, CentOS oder halt ein echtes Red Hat oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, manche stehen auch auf Suse und in neuster Zeit ganz, ganz im Trend für irgendwelche Minimalsysteme, so Alpinen und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber mir ist es genau umgedreht. Ich finde lustigerweise, auf dem Desktop kann ich Ubuntu nicht ausstehen.
Ich habe viele Anfälle, wenn ich Ubuntu verwenden muss auf dem Desktop.
Auf dem Desktop kommt bei mir bloß Manjaro mit I3.
Aber auf meinem Server-System, den ich privat betreibe, ist alles Ubuntu Server, weil es mir persönlich einfach am besten gefällt.
Ich finde, dass Ubuntu Server hat genau die richtige Auswahl an Aktualität von Paketen, das was Debian oftmals irgendwie nicht hat.
Aktualität von Paketen, ordentlicher Support, sinnvolle vorinstallierte Sachen
und ein paar Ausrutscher, wie der komische Yammel-basierte Netzwerk-Config haben sie.
Aber ansonsten finde ich, ist Ubuntu einfach servermäßig das beste Gesamtpaket.
Aber das ist ein bisschen Geschmackssache und letztendlich nimmt sich auch alles nicht so viel.
Wir müssen jetzt nämlich erst nochmal...
Was geht mit meinem Rechner? Warum ist denn da so am...
Was ist denn da so ausgelastet?
OBS, ja gut, OBS darf ausgelastet sein.
So, ich schalte mal wieder um.
Wir müssen uns erstmal...
Jetzt neueste Ubuntu Server-Dings downloaden.
Und auf den USB-Stick ziehen.
Jetzt ist bloß die Preisfrage, was nehme ich denn? Nehme ich einen 18.10?
Da muss ich nämlich nächstes Jahr updaten oder nehme ich einen 1804 LTS?
Ich glaube, ich nehme 1804 LTS.
Einfach aus dem Grund, dass haben sie, glaube ich, 5 Jahre supportet.
Das ist so drauf und Ruhe haben.
Hier muss ich quasi spätestens nach einem Jahr updaten, sonst gibt es keine Repos mehr zum ordentlich updaten.
Und das mache ich eh nicht.
Insofern nehme ich einen 1804.
So, und ich glaube, wir brauchen den Alternative-Installer.
Mal gucken, weil die haben mit irgendwie einer der letzten Versionen ihren Installer geändert.
Und der war übelster Crap. Du konntest kaum was machen.
Wir gucken mal.
Lifeserver, ja, das ist Fail, das ist die falsche.
Alternative-Dingsbums, brauchen wir.
Das ist Fail. Diesen komischen Live-Installer von Ubuntu kann man komplett knicken.
Da kannst du gar nichts machen.
Kannst du nicht mal Festplatten-Verschlüsselungen...
Warum, Entwoplos, was war?
Knäherbeer, was meinste?
Was meinste?
Äh, Standard, bla, bla, bla.
AMD, ARM, ja, den da wollen wir haben.
Das Installing, ja, du kannst in dem neuen Ubuntu-Installer...
Du kannst beispielsweise keine Positionierung mehr richtig machen.
Du kannst irgendwie keine... Was war es?
Ich glaube, du kannst keine Plattenverschlüsselung mehr richtig einrichten während der Installation.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Guck mal, das Ding hier.
New Installer.
Warte mal, vielleicht gibt es ein paar Bilder davon.
Ja, das da, das da.
Du kannst im Prinzip nicht viel machen, außer den Namen angeben.
Du konntest hier auch keine Verschlüsselung mehr einrichten.
Es ging ein paar Sachen nicht, die mir mega auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Deswegen nehme ich den Alternative-Installer.
Und das hier ist der normale.
Ja, genau, das ist der Mist.
So, machen wir mal einen USB-Stick rein.
Ich habe ja in weißer Voraussicht schon mal einen hin...
...geschmissen.
Ist die Musik-Lautstärke eigentlich so okay?
What?
The following device can be... Jaja, ist okay, mach.
Hat er hoffentlich schon connected.
Alter, Musik, wo sie im Hintergrund labern, ist nervig.
Def SD?
Na, wahrscheinlich B, hä?
Die Musik geht mir auf den Kicks.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Äh, 24-7 Chill-Music.
24, 24-7...
Rainy Jazz!
Oh, nee.
Overwatch-Musik.
Ah, warte mal.
Overwatch Christmas Extended.
Ja.
De, de, de, de, de, de, de, de.
Da wirst du aber verrückt mit der Zeit, weil das Loop nach einer Minute...
Das Loop nach einer Minute, das hält man nicht lange aus.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Woop, woop, woop.
Das ist mir schon zugechillt.
Crills im Cover, Klicks.
Da wird auch gesungen.
Ah, wir machen Dings ja.
Wie hieß die...
Den da, den machen wir an.
Das ist auch immer entspannt.
Japanische Fingerskills.
Das ist übrigens entspannt.
Bunker Toss.
Darf man jetzt ja gar nicht mehr spielen, oder?
Viel zu leise.
Das ist schön entspannt.
Also bloß gucken, dass es nicht zu laut ist.
So, gehen wir mal rüber.
Hat der Kram jetzt downloadet? Nee, der downloadet noch.
Also, guck mal, was ist das? Ist das hier auch der USB-Stick?
Ja, 16G, 15G sieht sehr nach USB-Stick aus.
So, die einfache Variante...
Also, sagen wir mal so, die zurzeit angesagteste Variante,
generell einen ISO auf einen USB-Stick zu bekommen, ist tatsächlich Etcher.
Ich weiß nicht genau...
Ich hab das eigentlich hauptsächlich für SD-Karten.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, warum man eine Elektronenanwendung braucht
mit zig MB Speicherverbrauch und 150 MB Downloadgröße oder so.
Und was weiß ich, wie viel...
Was weiß ich, wie viel RAM verbrauche?
Ja, so ein G, na nichts, das ist wirklich nicht wirklich so.
160 MB RAM-Verbrauch für ISOs auf einen Image machen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Man kann einfach auch...
Jetzt wird was aber wissen, hä?
Bisschen laut.
Ist immer schwierig einzuschätzen, weil so klemmiert die...
Das schwankt immer so.
So, anstatt einfach die CD auf den USB-Stick zu dd'n.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sich Etcher oder sowas durchgesetzt hat, keine Ahnung.
Man könnte einfach sagen, dd...
Ich mein, dd ist halt so der Disk-Destroyer schlechthin.
Das heißt übrigens, dd hat einen ganz abgetreten Namen.
Also das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht.
Genau, es heißt Copy and Convert oder Convert and Copy heißt dd.
Und wer kennt die Story dahinter, warum Copy and Convert oder Convert and Copy dd heißt?
Das ist irgendwie bescheuert, das müsste eigentlich Copy und Convert, das müsste eigentlich...
C and C oder so heißen oder CC oder CC...
Hm, C oder so.
Aber warum heißt das dd?
Also um das aufzuklären, warum das dd heißt, das ist...
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Story stimmt.
Die Sache ist, dass CC schon der C-Compiler ist.
Und die mussten das Ding einfach dd nennen, weil CC schon belegt war.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, aber das kann ich mir zu der damaligen Zeit gut vorstellen.
Das wird übelst leiser, das ist Fail.
Ich lasse jetzt einfach auf 30 und wenn es zu laut, das müsst ihr was sagen.
So, also mit dd'n ist jetzt nämlich einfach drauf.
Ups, da muss man halt ein bisschen aufpassen bei dd, ne?
Download, so wie hieß der Krampel Ubuntu?
Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal nach.
Dd in Home, Test, Downloads, Ubuntu, blablabla.
Of ist devsdb, haben wir vorher nachgeguckt.
Können wir nochmal nachgucken.
Ich hab den USB-Stick angestürzt und das ist der Meinung, er ist sdb.
Also, nice, wunderbar.
Sdb und sagen wir Blocksize 1M, dass es ein bisschen zackig ergeht.
So, und bei dd muss man jetzt doppelt und dreifach ganz genau gucken, dass da Kram auch stimmt.
Weil dd juckt es überhaupt nicht.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt hier bei of aus Versehen sda schreibe und sda ist meine...
Dann machen sie eben klein.
Achso, ja gut, das ganze muss ich als Hut machen, darf ich nicht.
Dann wäre mein Ding im Arsch.
Deswegen könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass...
Ja, jetzt USB-Sticks so vor sich hin.
Achso, ja, man kriegt, wenn man wissen möchte, was dd macht,
kann man sich den dd-Befehl raussuchen.
Irgendwo da.
Und man kann den Kill-Dings an dd schicken.
Und wenn man Glück hat, macht dann dd eine Status-Ausgabe, was es jetzt aber irgendwie nicht macht.
Normalerweise sollte es dd machen.
So, also das heißt, man kriegt bei dd nicht mit, was es gerade kopiert.
Das geht aber relativ einfach, man kann einfach.
Wir brechen das mal ab.
Ja.
Wir brechen das ab, also wenn wir das abgebrochen haben dann irgendwann.
Dann zeige ich euch, wie man dd anzeigen lassen kann, wie viel es eigentlich kopiert.
Was ist denn das Problem? Ist der USB-Stick nicht richtig drin oder was?
Keine Ahnung.
Dd, du darfst jetzt abbrechen.
Ah, jetzt.
Gut, jetzt ist er abgebrochen.
Genau, und man kann einfach sagen.
Hab ich dings, hab ich schon mal installiert?
Ja.
Man kann einfach sagen, man nimmt ein dd, piept das durch pv und dann wird er in dd.
Was das macht ist, pv ist quasi das liest Eingabe und schreibt es nach Ausgabe und sagt, wie viel es durchläuft.
Das heißt, im Prinzip kriegt man so, muss man eigentlich jetzt beides Blocks heißen?
Angeben, weiß ich gar nicht.
Im Prinzip kriegt man so raus, was dd treibt.
Ja und genau das, was knerbe schreibt, man kann damit auch einfach die Festplatten kopieren.
Das überhaupt kein Ding.
So, hier brauchen wir kein dd.
Scheinbar brauchen wir hier das dd vor, oder?
Reicht das noch mal so komplett?
Gucke.
Gucke?
Nee, da muss das dd da vorn.
Das ist logisch.
Beim Lesen nicht, aber beim Schreiben.
So, und jetzt zeigt es nämlich pv an, was es treibt.
Oder auch nicht.
Warum nicht?
Hast du denn was verkehrt gemacht?
Eigentlich sollte das genau so funktionieren.
Wir können mit ds danach gucken, was das kopiert.
Ja, das kopiert.
Das kopiert auf dem USB-Stick.
Ich weiß aber gar nicht, warum die dd nichts anzeigt, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist blöd auch irgendwie.
Das traue ich genau richtig.
Naja, warten wir mal ab, bis es auf den USB-Stick geschrieben hat.
Also, Casgorian, das kann man machen.
Das verursacht halt ein bisschen Last auf dem Rechner.
Keine Lemonbar.
Nein, es ist...
Wie heißt das Ding?
I3...
I3-Status-RS.
Das ist irgendwie irgendeine Rust-Geschichte.
Rust...
Was da?
Ja, I3-Status.
Rust ist es.
Es ist keine Lemonbar.
Es gibt ja...
Ah, okay, er ist fertig.
Er ist fertig.
Warum pv nichts angezeigt, ehrlich gesagt.
Also im Prinzip ist das die richtige Variante, wenn man sich was anzeigen lassen will.
So, und nun können wir unser Board mit dem USB-Stick booten und hoffen, dass es funktioniert.
Ich versuche das mal dran zu steppseln gerade.
Moment, wir gehen mal rüber.
Und ich schalte mal auf die Elgato um.
Und wir gucken mal, ob der jetzt vom USB-Stick bootet.
Ah, ich muss noch kurz das Kopfhörer absetzen und dann schmeißen wir irgendwas runter.
So.
Und einschalten.
Zack.
Und mal gucken, ob es startet.
Ach so, vielleicht sollte ich noch eine Tastatur anschließen.
Das wäre nicht schlecht.
Aber man sieht schon mal, was haben wir.
Er ist schon mal der Meinung, er ist auf billiges Rock-Main-Board, was erstmal ganz gut ist.
Ja, wunderbar.
Was nun?
Elgato, wo ist denn jetzt das Problem?
Hallo, Elgato.
Was genau hat das Ding für Probleme?
Okay, dann stöpsel ich das Elgato-Teil noch mal ab und wieder an.
Auch okay.
Vielleicht bringt es ja mehr.
Ha?
Ha!
Was ist das denn?
Ach nee, Moment, das hat jetzt ja das gebootet, was schon auf der Platte drauf ist.
Das ist total bescheuert.
Da muss ich noch mal eine Tastatur dran stöpseln und mal entknoten und rebooten.
So.
Das ist ganz schönes Gefuddel hier, weil das Board liegt quasi...
Warum hat die Tastatur eigentlich zwei USB-Anschlüsse?
Hm.
Das muss ich gleich mal beim Hersteller nachgucken.
Warum?
Kennt ihr das, dass man USB-Anschlüsse immer falsch rum reinstöpselt?
Immer.
Aber am vierten Anlauf oder so hat man festgestellt, es ist doch verkehrt rum oder richtig rum gewesen.
So.
Okay, meine...
Okay, starten wir mal neu.
Was muss man drücken?
Entfernen?
Was muss man drücken fürs BIOS?
Ich sehe ja nichts, weil die Elgato nicht mag.
Ah, okay.
Ha.
Entfernen, einfach entfernen.
Herr Mann, um gut ist.
Wo kann man einstellen, was man booten will?
Ja.
Ich will nicht Ubuntu, ich will das da booten.
Hä.
Wie sagt man ihm denn, von was er booten soll?
Da muss man... Nee, da muss man wahrscheinlich beim Booten irgendwie...
Achso, nee, hier kann man das wohl auch auswählen.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ah, bam.
Funktioniert doch.
Moment, ich muss mir das hier selbst erstmal Vollbild machen.
Weil sonst sehe ich das nicht.
Ich mache das selbst gerade über die OBS-Vorschau.
Das ist voll fail, ja.
Ich habe nicht den Monitor-Pass-Route oder so.
Ich mache das mit übelst dem Lack über die Elgato-Vorschau gerade.
Okay, also, Language ist Englisch, ist okay.
Ich drücke ein Tast, das macht eine Minute später was.
Das ist übelst irritierend.
Nein, wir sind in EU.
Nicht Simbabwe.
So, dann sind wir in Germany.
Wir sind doch nicht in Simbabwe.
Ja, übrigens, US ist in Ordnung.
Kann ich mitleben.
Yes, Tastatur layout detected, please.
Y, jawoll.
Y, jawoll, yes, wir haben auch einen Ö-Key.
Drücke den Ö-Key.
Das ist jetzt gefühlt, nein, wir sind keine Franzosen.
Wir haben detected, dass du DE-No-Dead-Keys hast, jawoll.
So, das geht jetzt relativ schnell.
Und danach kann ich mich bei SSH einloggen.
Guck mal, ich habe einen Addon in meinem Memeboard drinne.
Ich kann jetzt, zeig euch was, ich hab jetzt im Vollbild,
ihr seht jetzt ja quasi Vollbild Elgato,
und ich kann trotzdem Bilder einpletten.
Ist nice, oder?
Ich hab jetzt nämlich den Browser-Output vom Meme-Tool.
Das ist schon Pock.
So, Hostname.
Den, wie heißt der jetzt?
Wir brauchen einen guten Namen für das Ding.
Korgas.
Oder, ähm, was hab ich denn noch nicht?
Ich hab schon so viel.
Korgas, ja Korgas ist gut.
Ich grabe das selber Korgas.
Oder Broggas.
Ich hab übrigens Broggas als Domain doch registriert, ne?
Die wir letztens im Stream gesehen haben.
Fullname for new user.
Max.
Hoch, wahnsinnig secure Passwort.
Nicht Porgas, Broggas.
Äh, ja ja, das ist schon okay.
Timezone, jawoll.
So sieht's aus.
Die, die, die, die, die, die.
Ja ja, das ist okay, mach weiter.
Use entire disks and setup encrypted LVM.
Das klingt gut.
Hauptsache man muss den Crap nicht selber machen.
Ja.
Cleverer Installer.
Was möchten Sie formatieren?
Die Festplatte oder den USB-Stick von dem Sie gerade...
Was, muted?
Bin ich muted?
Gebaided, äh, ah.
Weil das hätte, das hätte tatsächlich sein können, dass ich muted bin.
Weil, ähm, ich hab ja die, die Szene im OBS gewechselt.
Huge Gebaid.
Die, die, die, die, die, die.
Yes.
Moin Onkel Bingo.
Passwort Encryption Phrase.
Ja, das werdet ihr jetzt nicht erfahren.
Oh nee.
Also 123456.
So 12345789.
Ja, ja, richtig.
Jaja, mach einfach weiter.
Yes.
Ja, das war's.
Passwort.
Moin, Danny D.
Ich bin begeistert, wie schnell mittlerweile so eine bunte Installation ist.
Ich kann mich noch an die ersten paar Missionen erinnern, die haben teilweise echt irgendwie
eine halbe Stunde oder so rumgerödelt.
Aber das lag wahrscheinlich auch daran, dass die Recher damals langsamer waren.
Ich habe mich damals für super clever gehalten und ich habe damals auf einem ollen Rechner
habe ich ein Ubuntu, was war denn das, keine Ahnung, 8.10 oder so etwas oder 9.
alt, ganz alt, habe ich ein Ubuntu installiert auf einem USB-Stick RAID 1, da habe ich damals
übelst gefeiert früher, weil ich gedacht habe, boah ist das geil, ist das der RAID
1, da brauchst du keine Platten, boah, ja, da habe ich mich übelst gefeiert damals,
dass ich einen USB-Stick RAID 1 habe.
Ich glaube, das hätte man nur noch toppen können mit einem Micro SD Karten RAID 5 oder
so etwas.
Das wäre doch mal was, oder?
Was sagt ihr, was, das wäre doch mal was, ein Micro SD Karten RAID 5.
So, dass auch schön alle SD Karten gleichmäßig kaputt gehen.
Auf, installieren, go go, war nicht so lange rum, yo dog, ein kein Proxy, Proxy ist komplett
overrated.
Qwaii, was hast du denn installiert für eine Distribution, was ist denn aktuell für eine
Distribution sinnvoll für so Low-End-Hardware?
Vor einer Weile habe ich bei meiner Mutter auf dem Notebook, die hat auch so ein olles,
alles, ich weiß auch nicht, ob es auch ein Toolcore ist, so ein olles Ding, da habe ich
ein elementary drauf installiert, das läuft gut, so, was wollen wir haben, wir wollen
eigentlich nur einen Open SSH Server, dass wir uns darauf eindoggen können, das ist eigentlich
alles, mehr wollen wir nicht, so, und jetzt machen wir hinne, ich meine, das installieren
geht schon relativ schnell, ne, das ist eine SD Karte, ne, eine SSD und ein USB Stick,
ein ordentlicher, also das geht schon zackig, ich kann mich noch an Zeiten erinnern, da
musste ich mal, das ist jetzt wirklich, das ist jetzt wirklich lang her, da habe ich mal
auf einem Server im Rechenzentrum, Red Hat, was war das, vier oder so installiert auf
einer Datenbank, das waren damals glaube ich sechs CDs, da hast du wirklich drei Stunden
davor gestanden und hast CDs gewechselt, das waren echt, das war ein richtiger Kopf, übelster
Kack, ey, weil, und vor allem hat es damals so lange gedauert, weil sich irgendjemand
überlegt hat, so in glorreicher Voraussicht, dass sie auf ihren Daten, das ist kein Witz,
ne, dass sie auf ihren Datenbanken eine Red Hat Vollinstallation haben wollen, also sprich
alles, komplett, überall ein Häkchen machen, man durfte auch nicht im Installer einfach
sagen Vollinstallation, nein, man musste Custom Installation machen und überall ein Häkchen
hin, die wollten, die wollten nicht eine Vollinstallation, die wollten eine volle, vollständige Vollinstallation
haben und da hast du dann alles sechs CDs für gebraucht, das hat ewig gedauert, ja,
ich denke mal, mittlerweile wollen sie sowas auch nicht mehr, das ist schon bescheuert,
oder, true story, das ist halt, so in Zeiten, als ich noch Turnschuh-Administrator war,
also, im Prinzip Azubi, der rumlaufen musste, ach so, Azubi, ja, ist schon ein bisschen
her, ist auf jeden Fall über zehn Jahre her, noch länger, ja, schon ein bisschen, zwölf
Jahre oder so, ja, und ich war schon relativ spät, cool story pro, ja, was soll ich sonst
machen, wenn wir uns die umwundene Installation angucken, so super intense Gameplay ist das
jetzt ja nicht, ich meine, das ist voll immersive, das Gameplay, da kann man nichts anderes sagen,
ja, wir können ja mal deine IHK Prüfung-Stream angucken, das Problem ist, ich hätte schon,
ich hätte schon mal aus Just For Fun, hätte ich schon mal eine IHK Prüfung aufgemacht
im Stream, und wir hatten uns das mal zusammen angeguckt, weil die sind teilweise echt sowas
von bescheuert, das Problem ist, die gehen da voll ab, ja, die machen da das ultra Geheimnis
drum, um die IHK Prüfung, ja, also ich sag mal so, wenn ich die nicht im Stream runterladen
muss, wenn einer von euch mir einen Link schickt, wo zufällig eine IHK Prüfung dahinter ist,
dann kann ich ja eigentlich auch nichts dagegen tun, ja, so, wir sind fertig, complete, bam,
danach können wir uns bei SSH einloggen, gut, vielleicht hätte ich dem Ding mal eine feste
IP geben sollen, das ist overrated, man bleibt overrated, guck ich halt bei mir im PSSens
nach, was ist für eine IP gekriegt dann, an der ersten mal noch Passwort eintippen,
Elgato, wo ist denn, Alter, riesige komische Capture Card, da musste immer das Kabel rein
und raus machen, das kann doch nicht sein, so, jetzt gehts wieder, ganz komisch, Unlock,
ja ja, Unlock Koggers, wir unlocken Koggers, das ist das erste, was wir machen müssen,
dass wir über SSH den Rechner anlocken können, weil ich hab keinen Bock, mich jedes Mal an
den Rechner dran zu stöpseln, ok, nice, wir gucken nochmal kurz, was wir für eine IP
gekriegt haben, wenn wir schon grad da sind, IP-Add, wir nehmen auch das neue, ja, auch
wenn ich, 2, 1, 5, 3, auch wenn ich irgendwie immer noch so über die Jahre an if-config
gewöhnt bin, irgendwie, tja, weiß nicht, muss ich mich da langsam mal dran gewöhnen,
so, switchen wir mal zurück und gehen in unsere VM und stöpseln die Tastatur mal wieder
ab und locken uns da per SSH drauf ein, in der Hoffnung, dass ich jetzt nirgends runterschmeiße,
so, und ich muss unbedingt mal nachgucken, warum meine Tastatur zwei USB-Anschlüsse
hat, das verstehe ich nicht, das müssen wir jetzt grad mal nachgucken, warum hat die
zwei USB-Anschlüsse, ähm, ah, verstehe ja nicht, warum hat die, ja, why 2S, genau das
frage ich mich auch grade, achso, die Tastatur hat noch ne USB, den man da drüber, ah, wer
benutzt denn sowas, das zweite Kabel ist einfach nur durchgeschleiftes USB, ist ja langweilig,
so, add, ja, super Secret Passwort, MaxEdKorras am Start, so, erst mal Update machen und danach
stellen wir ein, was wir anlocken können per SSH, das ist das Allerwichtigste, hab ich
schon ne Weile nicht mehr gemacht, vergess ich jedes Mal, wie es funktioniert, aber ist
nicht sonderlich schwierig, da brauchen wir den SSH-Sorber, der startet, während wir
booten und dann geben wir dann per SSH das Passwort ein, dann bootet es weiter, schau
mal gleich, äh, Update, Tastatur, please, äh, hallo Max, machst du mal ein Video über
deine Shortcuts, wie du zwischen deinem Maschinenwechsel und so weiter und wie du das setzt, würde
ich halt sehr interessieren, da ich diesen tollen Workflow unterliegen zu bekommen, äh,
du meinst das hier, auf Windows und dann auf Linux, äh, das ist relativ simpel gesagt,
also du kannst ja, du kannst ja unter Windows kannst du ja die Desktop switchen mit, äh,
Control, Windows-Taste und File-Tasten, kannst du Desktop switchen und das kannst du dir
dann einfach, ich hab mir das als Makro gelegt, ich weiß, dass ich Update eingetippt hab,
das ist, das war schon Absicht, achso, dann hast du einfach nur voll mit, äh, ich kann
dir das Makro mal zeigen, jetzt ist es ein bisschen komplizierter als das Makro, ähm,
also auf meine Haupt, das ist das Makro, was wir letztens im Stream gemacht haben, ähm,
Kakosa-Software, äh, bei mir auf, äh, bei meinem Arbeits, äh, Account hab ich es auf
der Maus, hab ich es auf der mittleren Maustaste über den Logitech-Test-Driver gemacht, äh,
und zwar, im Prinzip macht das Makro genau das, das drückt, äh, Left, äh, Steuerung,
Windows-Taste rechts, Steuerung, Windows-Taste rechts und dann macht es noch, was ganz praktisch
ist, dann drückt ALT und V und geht auf Exclusive-Mode, dass ich hier nicht Probleme hab, wenn ich
am Rand irgendwie rumfuddele, so, und dann hab ich auf G2 einfach wieder den, äh, auf
1 wieder das Makro, um auf Windows zurückzugehen, das kannst du aber auch auf deine Logitech-Maus
legen, ist kein Problem, oder aber, wenn du keine programmierbare Maus oder Tastatur
hast, machst du einfach Steuerung, Windows-Taste und rechte Dinge, da musst du halt noch einmal
reinklicken danach, dass es wieder funktioniert. Und das hier ist einfach nur vor allem im Vollbild,
genau. Äh, gibt's einen Grund, warum du Windows benutzt und darauf Linux in der Vorhand nur
aus Interesse, ähm, weil die anderen Sachen, die ich mache, an Windows brauchen, also ich
mache auf der, ich wollt grad sagen, ich mache YouTube-Videos, ich hab jetzt in relativ
letzter Zeit wenig YouTube-Videos gemacht, aber normalerweise mach ich YouTube-Videos
und ähm, Audio-Video-Zeug und vor allem halt von Games, das kannst du halt unter Linux
nicht machen. Nachdem ich aber die anderen Sachen viel lieber unter Linux mach, ist die
einfachere Variante, Linux unter Windows zu laufen, zu bekommen, als alles andere, was
ich von Windows brauche, unter Linux. Das ist einfach die einfache, so, so rum ist einfacher.
So, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie das funktioniert hat. Also, wenn man seine, seinen Server anlocken
möchte, beim Booten über SSH, weil das ist ja sinnvoll, wenn man sich überlegt, man
hat die Festplatte verschlüsselt und den Server irgendwo stehen, ja, sei es nur im
Keller, also irgendwo, wo man nicht hinlaufen möchte und starte den neu, dann ist es ja
so, dass man beim Starten immer das Passwort eingeben muss zum Festplattenentschlüsseln,
weil sonst kann man nicht booten und man kann das Ganze auch per SSH machen, dazu muss
man sich einen minimalen SSH-Server installieren, der quasi beim Booten schon gestartet wird,
auf dem man dann das Passwort eintippt. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich simpel, wenn man
weiß, wie es geht und ich vergesse das jedes Mal, wie es funktioniert und danach stell
ich fest, eigentlich war es total einfach. Also, eigentlich ITSRF. Ich weiß nur, dass
wir TROP-Bier installieren müssen. TROP-Bier. Bär. TROP-Bär. Für SSH beim Booten. So,
das ist installiert. Mach mal zu. So, und jetzt müssen wir glaube ich TROP-Bär. Ja,
Steinex, irgendwie so, das ist ziemlich simpel gewesen. Install TROP-Bier Init, ja, das da
müssen wir installieren. Und ich glaube fast das war's mehr oder weniger. Es war wirklich
ganz schwierig. Genau, danach muss man auch irgendwo einstellen, dass es... Invalid-Auswahl,
ach nee, wir müssen erst, okay, okay, okay, okay, nee, wir müssen erst noch irgendwo
ein ordentliches authorized-key-File hinschieben. Auch okay, machen wir. Machen wir alles. TROP-Bier
ist ein mini SSH-Server, den man beim Booten schon starten kann, über den man dann seine
Festplatte anlocken kann, um weiter zu booten. So, und das erste, was wir jetzt machen, ist
wir locken uns nochmal aus und sagen SSH-Copy-ID, dass wir uns da jetzt ohne Passwort einloggen
können. Das ist wichtig. Ups. Jaja, ich wollte das eigentlich auch nicht drücken, so. Okay,
er löste aber nicht den SSH-Server ab, sondern nur beim Boot richtig. Richtig. Ich glaube,
man musste das sogar einstellen, dass der sich beendet irgendwie danach. So, wo war
das jetzt? etc-defaults-trop, nee, pc-trop-bier-trop, hier, da, config. Da muss man doch IP und
so einstellen irgendwo. Da muss ich mal nachgucken. Da muss man, da muss man gerade mal in den
Guide angucken. Ich vergesse, wie gesagt, ich vergesse jedes Mal, wie das wieder krempeln
funktioniert. So, und authorized-key können wir eigentlich aber hinkopieren aus meinem
Heimatverzeichnis, dass das, mal gucken, ob das dann so funktioniert. Da ist dann mein
Key drinnen. Guck mal, da gibt's bestimmt ein Guide für. Ich warte schon 10 Monate
auf das Antivirus-Video. Hab ich nicht ein Antivirus-Video gemacht? Hab ich doch. Hab
ich doch. Hier, da. Guck mal. Wie, Antivironsoftware noch sinnvoll oder sogar gefährlich? Hab
ich gesagt, hab ich noch was dazu echt? Was wollte ich denn noch dazu sagen? Ja, Buzzi-Box
brauchen wir auf jeden Fall, dass wir eine Shell haben beim Einloggen. Ah, etc-defaults-trop-bier
sollen wir editieren. Machen wir. Windows-Defender plus Uplog. Hab ich mittlerweile auch. Ja,
genau, Steinex. Im Prinzip schon. Das sowas in der Richtung kam dann im Endeffekt auch
raus bei den Videos. Ich hab gesagt, wenn Antivirus, kann man bei Windows-Defender bleiben, zusätzlichen
Gramm installieren muss man nicht. Oder ob man es wirklich braucht, ist eh fragwürdig.
Andere Betriebssysteme oder Smartphone, ah, da kann ich wirklich mal was zu sagen. Auf
dem Smartphone bin ich mittlerweile unschlüssig, ob man sowas braucht. Also ursprünglich hätte
ich immer gesagt, braucht man nicht. Totaler Blödsinn. Aber nachdem es immer mehr Smartphone-Dinger
gibt, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob man das braucht oder nicht. Ich tendiere
aber eher zu nahe, braucht man nicht. Ach so, ja, immer. Das wichtigste, was man zuerst
auf jedem Linux-System installiert, ist ein ordentlichen Vim, dass man nicht sich mit
diesem Gremple rumschlagen muss. Das schon Vim vorinstalliert hat, okay. Man installiert
einen Vim und man installiert einen T-Max. Das ist das wichtigste. Das braucht man. Ohne.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, die Ubuntu-Standard-Installation, Ubuntu-Server ist ziemlich gut. Ist alles
drin, was man braucht. Ja, und eine Sache, die ich auch noch ganz gerne installiere,
ist das hier. Das, ähm, ist, mal angenommen, mal angenommen, mal angenommen, mal angenommen.
Das ist das, was ich gerne angenommen habe, das ist das, was ich gerne angenommen habe.
Das war's für heute.
Es war's für heute.
und so wirklich was wo man sagen würde hey das ding hat wenig kerne dafür ultra hoch
getaktet fällt mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nichts ein weil in der regel kannst du sagen umso
mehr kerne umso niedriger ist einzelne kerne getaktet aber ich denke mal mit dem aktuellsten
desktop cpu fest sind aber wahrscheinlich war das so schlecht ansonsten gibt es wahrscheinlich
auch irgendwie jixion oder so aber das zeug ist immer so ultra teuer du brauchst extra kühler extra
boards extra extra alles irgendwie so jetzt gucken wir mal ob das jetzt war das jetzt alles
was man machen musste das muss das musste hallo ich kann ich darf nicht mehr tippen in meiner
vm ok jetzt darf ich wieder tippen dass das habe ich auch noch nie gemacht
wobei ich bilde mir ein dass das genau splash haben wir noch gar nicht ich glaube das heißt
boah ich glaube das muss er nur auf dem desktop machen kraft updaten müssen wir eigentlich
auch nicht weil ich meine wir haben im endeffekt nichts gemacht reboot ok jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob das funktioniert haben wir haben wir in it things gab data der haben wir gucken
wir mal gucken wir mal ob wir jetzt beim booten anlocken können ich switch ich switch gleich
wieder rüber auf die auf die elgator guck das schöne an t-max ist jetzt ich kann jetzt
auch einfach ein zweites ein zweites tab aufmachen mich auf dem gleichen system noch mal einloggen
und hier unten gucken wo eigentlich die auslastung verursacht wird das ist schon praktisch ja oder
halt ein t-max auf dem system stand so wie rebooten mal ich hoffe ich habe jetzt nichts
nichts vergessen wenn ich muss ja mit tastatur anstöpseln genau ich muss den den namen
eingeben verbrechner kogas reboot bäm so und jetzt gehen wir rüber und schalten um auf die
elgator und offen die elgator elgator so vor sich hin
ach elga elgator warum verlierst du denn immer da eine macht es macht sich ja aha aha funktioniert
ach nee ich glaube wir haben vergessen den key hinzuzufügen oder haben wir nicht aber
nicht ja passt guck und jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich eingeloggt jetzt bin ich eingeloggt
quasi in so einem minimal system wo ich nichts anderes großartig machen kann außer halt
meine platte zu anlocken
zack und jetzt sehen wir jetzt ist es abgekackt hier an der stelle wenn ich jetzt wieder umschalte
können wir auch erbootet weiter zack ist gebootet its warum läuft denn der noch
es lässt sich noch optimieren das auf jeden fall nicht so schön
das sollte deswegen sollte man wahrscheinlich sein
was auf null nee das musste man auf null stellen dass er überhaupt startet beim booten
ach so ah moment bezieht sich das jetzt auf oder bezieht ich dachte das bezieht sich
aufs booten guck mal mal ob er jetzt meckert willst du dich jetzt beschweren dass du kein
geld ausgeben darfst knäherbär oder wie muss ich mich jetzt rechtfertigen dafür dass
du mir nicht dein geld geben darfst oder wie wo sind wir denn hier hallo ronics knäherbär
ja gut dann da muss ich mich ja wohl kümmern ok und jetzt ist halt die frage ist es startet
das jetzt noch
ne ne man muss das man muss das auf den muss das schon da reinschreiben oder ich bin ich
ja wir könnten dem dem ding wirklich einen anderen port geben egal ich mein
frau uns ja das ist ja nicht wild wir brauchen sie nur am neustart
ok also das funktioniert das prinzipial kann das ding anlocken beim starten das ist schon
mal das wichtigste so ok jetzt können wir zur eigentlichen sache kommen wir haben dann
verschlüsselt das system am start mit mit 400 500 g platte guck mal was habt ihr jetzt
gibt aber da haben wir eben schon gemacht soll jetzt nicht nichts mehr geben das kam
er verschlüsselt donation donation dass ich war wo hat donated 150 alter sie war was los
weihnachtsgelden zu null alter nahe vorgabe ganz so kann ich noch sagen hier easy easy nice
wie gesagt ihr müsst ja alle nichts tun wenn ihr nicht wollt aber wenn ihr wollt dann
habe ich natürlich auch nichts dagegen und wenn ich mich wenn ich mich sappt wenn ich
irgendwann mal ein sapp button habe wäre natürlich auch nice ich habe jetzt ich habe ja noch
fünf tagezeit sechs tagezeit mich drum zu kümmern dieses jahr das ja auch so weiter
im text also grundsätzlich die sache funktioniert schon mal wir haben wir haben eingerichtet
das finde ich das finde ich einfach aus versehen rebooten können jetzt haben wir mal ein t-max
rein soll es ist die frage jetzt geht es ja eigentlich da drauf was war jetzt ist bloß
die frage was wie wie machen wir das am besten also ich brauchte auf jeden fall also den
engine x brauche ich auf jeden fall drauf was google so an engine x brauche ich auf
jeden fall drauf will mehr emotes mach jetzt selbst wenn ich es jetzt machen würde wo
soll ich den emotes herkriegen da muss ich mir erstmal irgendeinen designer suchen die
gefühlt alle recht unzuverlässig sind ein raussuchen der ordentlich emotes machen kann
dann mich mit dem einig werden so mannetechnisch ich will erst sein ja ich machs ja schon nicht
ihr dürft mir alle bald mein geld euer geld geben ich will ja mal nicht so sein und dann
machen wir machen wir keks emotes und easy keks emotes und katz fps emotes und maus fps
emotes und alles ja engine x müssen wir installieren weil webserver brauche ich auf jeden fall
kommen wir nicht drum rum so wo ich ich bin mir jetzt echt unschlüssig wie ich das ganze
wie ich das ganze machen soll installiere ich den ganzen krempel einfach direkt auf
so einfach drauf mach ich lxd container oder mach ich für home assistant docker stell ich
weiß nicht ich weiß nicht was ich am besten mache weil eigentlich will ich es ja einfacher
machen als aktuell ich glaube wir machen lxd container mit das aber auch durfte den scheiß
muss er dann wieder updaten wir installieren alles auf das system drauf hast ein server
daheim ja nicht nur allen das ist gerade die ablöse für den fetten das ist gerade die
ablöse für den fetten den wir installieren achso ja stimmt ne ne ne ne sache die ganz
nutzle ist die bei ubuntu auch dabei ist das dings hier ist das so ne warte mal wie ist
der prompt der der der standardmessig temperatur und so was anzeigt das war nicht pure prompt
das war ich sein dann ist jetzt noch mal und ja da finde ich ganz weiß ich nehme immer
ganz gern zeug was schon was schon dabei ist irgendwie spackt meine vm wenn ich wenn
ich drüben klicke da habe ich mal entspannet irgendwas mit container und stells ne was
für für ich die benutze heimautomatisierungs zeug fernsehzeug ich hab ich hab es am anfang
noch gezeigt hier hast du einmal meine meine kvm vms falsche kiste ja ja ist ja gut open
sens netzberg gedöns dann heimautomatisierungs vm dann hab ich dann hab ich dann hab ich
hier jede menge containers drauf laufen für alle möglichen dinger und auf meine heimautomatisierungs
kiste hab ich noch docker gedöns laufen so und das ist mir einfach viel zu komplex und
viel zu single point of failure für mein zeug ehrlich gesagt ja das ding war relativ
teuer aber das war halt selbst konstruiert selbst gebaut sieht man ja hier im bitt da
ist aber auch komplett auf was heißt das teil das ist so mein mini reck mit dem 10g
switch unten drunter und hier oben ist halt sieht man kann man kann man reingucken also
das war halt relativ teuer und es ist halt komplett auf was heißt deswegen da hast du
2x 3x 10 terabyte platten drin einen 8 kern xeon 10 g anschlüsse ich glaub 48 g ram
nene nene nene nene nene nene nene nene nene nene nene adapter gedöns es ist einfach komplett
over oversized für mich ja gibts dann auch ein neues video wenn du alles gebaut hast
Das könnte man tatsächlich machen.
Die Namen der LXC-Container.
Ja, was meinst du, warum das neue System Kogas heißt?
Ja, und das Ziel ist, das fette 4HE-System
abzulösen durch drei kleinere Sachen,
die erstens weniger Strom verbrauchen und zweitens nicht mehr so
Single-Point-Of-Failure-mäßig sind.
Na, da kommt eine Mikrotik-Router hin, da kommt jetzt die Kiste, in die wir installieren,
für Heimautomatisierung, Fernsehen und alles, was ein bisschen Rechenleistung braucht.
Und, ähm,
dann so ein Single-Board-Computer mit 10T-Platte für
Backups.
Wie virtualisierst du verschiedene Server?
Ich hab noch gar keine Zeit.
Die paar sind mit KVM,
die anderen sind mit LXC und
Heimautomatisierungsteuerchen sind mit Docker. Das ist auch viel zu kompliziert.
Viel zu kompliziert.
So, wie mach ich das jetzt?
Ich bin unschlüssig.
Mach ich die Docker-Installation von Home Assistant oder mach ich
schon eine LXC-Kiste oder knall ich's einfach auf den Server selbst drauf?
Kannst du kurz Docker erklären?
Um Docker zu erklären...
Also, erstens bin ich nicht der großartige Docker-Fachmann, das muss man auch schon dabei sagen.
Also, das muss man wissen, was Linux-Container sind.
Im Prinzip ist eine Linux-Container
nichts anderes, wie ein 0.8.15-Prozess, den du auf deinem Linux-System startest.
Also sprich,
zwischen
einem Hardtop, was du ausführst,
und einem Hardtop im Container ist erstmal kein Unterschied.
Das sind beides ganz normale Hardtop-Prozesse.
Der Unterschied ist,
dass, wenn du einen Container startest, mit
Hardtop drinne,
das Hardtop ein bisschen abgeschottet ist mit
extra Namespaces
und mit, äh,
wie heißt der Kram?
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt. Wie heißt es?
Sie ist Z-Groups, Z-Groups, ja.
Das heißt, du hast so ein paar Sachen wie
Hostname, Netzwerke-Access, Disk-Io und sowas in der Richtung
ist quasi gefiltert
und du kannst ein paar Sachen in einem Container nicht machen. Was du zum Beispiel
in einem Container nicht machen kannst,
sind Kernel-Module laden.
Das wäre nämlich auch ein bisschen scheiße, wenn du aus einem
Container Kernel-Module laden könntest.
Du hast da keinen Zugriff aus dem Container draus.
Das führt natürlich dazu, dass die Dinger ein bisschen
besser isoliert voneinander laufen.
Allerdings, dadurch, dass es nach wie vor ein ganz normaler
Prozess ist auf deiner Linux-Kiste, so wie alles andere auch,
sind Container relativ schnell.
Also im Prinzip hast du überhaupt keinen Unterschied
zwischen so gut wie keinen,
eigentlich gar keinen,
Unterschied zwischen einem Prozess, den du bei dir auf dem Hostsystem startest oder
ein Prozess, den du quasi
auf deinem Hostsystem startest mit noch ein bisschen Containerzeug drumherum.
Das heißt, so viel Unterschied zu einem normalen Prozess
ist ein Container nicht.
Und das ist alles LXC. Das ist
wohlgemerkt, dass
Containergeschichten im Kernel nennen sich LXC.
Das verwenden alle Containerisierungsgeschichten.
Es verwenden alle das Gleiche. Es verwenden alle LXC im Kernel.
Docker macht keine Container.
LXD macht auch keine Container.
Was gibt es denn da noch so alles? Ranger und hast du nicht gesehen,
die machen alle keine Container.
Die verwenden alle
Namespaces, Sea Groups und das Gedöns, was im Kernel drin ist.
Und was Docker jetzt macht, ist einen Weg quasi
Container,
den Containererstellungsprozess
zu vereinheitlichen und zu automatisieren.
Also Docker ist quasi
ein User Interface für
die Containerfunktion im Kernel.
Und das ist auch nicht das einzige.
Docker ist aber mit Abstand das bekannteste und verbreitetste.
Das heißt, man nutzt quasi, um verschiedene Dinge ein bisschen
besser voneinander zu trennen.
Ja, wobei der hauptsächliche Scham von Docker ist,
diese Sache mit, dass die Sachen voneinander getrennt laufen,
ist sicherlich auch ein Punkt.
Aber der hauptsächliche Scham von Docker, und das ist auch das, wo es herkommt,
wo es heute leider ein bisschen
zu anderen Dingern missbraucht wird,
das Scham von Docker und die ursprüngliche Idee hinter Docker war,
dass du,
wenn du Sachen entwickelst
und es testen möchtest,
dass du dann relativ schnell
dir ein Testsystem starten können willst.
Was nach Möglichkeiten die Sachen installiert hat, die deine Produktivsysteme
auch installiert haben oder installiert haben werden.
Oder im besten Fall lässt du einfach den gleichen Container
auf deinen Produktionsservern laufen.
Wobei dafür ist es eigentlich nie gedacht gewesen, auch wenn man das heute
mittlerweile macht, aber
eigentlich ist es dafür nie gedacht gewesen.
Es ist gedacht für Entwicklersysteme,
die man sich schnell
spawnen kann, um darauf was auszuprobieren im Endeffekt.
Und wo alle Sachen, die du als Abhängigkeiten hast für deine Anwendung
mit dabei sind.
Das ist eigentlich der große Pluspunkt von Docker.
Also sprich, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel hier,
sag mal, warum kann ich hier nicht klicken, warum muss ich jetzt immer rein
rausswischen, was ist das für ein
Müll?
Geht das ein bisschen mit Docker?
Verstehe nicht, ob ihr das kennt.
Nicht den Docker Hub.
Den Docker Hub. So, da kannst du jetzt zum Beispiel mal suchen nach
einen Samba Server oder so.
Und da findest du zig
vorgefertigte
Samba
Container, aber es sind eigentlich gar keine Container.
Weil alles, was das ist
auf Docker Hub
sind im Prinzip
Config Files,
wie dein Docker
den Container bei dir lokal dann erstellt.
Ja, ich mach das ja.
Ich mach aber kein Affiliate, ich schreib Twitch an.
Ja, genau und
wie du hier siehst,
im Prinzip ist das, auch wenn man sagt, so quasi auf Docker Hub gibt es Container,
das stimmt gar nicht,
auf Docker Hub gibt es Docker Files,
wo dann drinne steht,
wie so ein Container erstellt wird.
Also im Prinzip steht da so was drinne wie From Alpine, also sprich die nehmen als Base,
Base Iso, nehmen sie so ein Alpine Image, das ist ein relativ Light-White Linux.
Wohlgemerkt, auch wenn da drinne steht From Alpine,
es ist kein Alpine Linux. Spricht man das überhaupt so aus?
Es ist kein Alpine Linux, was läuft.
Es läuft weiterhin in Ubuntu
mit dem gleichen Kernel.
Also sprich,
es läuft alles auf diesem Kernel
und im Prinzip,
wie wenn du den Prozess einfach so starten würdest,
das Einzige, was sie von
Alpine verwenden ist
der Netz.
Das Einzige, was sie von Alpine verwenden, ist halt
die Umgebung, also sprich die Libraries, die dabei sind und alles Mögliche.
Nicht den Kernel, weil das ist ja keine richtige VM.
So und dann macht er hier gedürnt und am Ende startet Docker und ist da.
Also Docker ist quasi so ein schöner Weg, sich erstens Entwicklersysteme
schnell hinzustellen, die halt auch immer gleich sind. Du könntest zum Beispiel sagen,
hey, wir bauen uns, wir entwickeln jetzt ein toller
Videokonferenzsoftware und
die wollen wir, während wir die entwickeln, wollen wir die testen
und das heißt, wir bauen uns mal so einen Docker-File, was quasi
ja so ungefähr ähnlich ist, als unsere Produktivsysteme und die kann dann jeder
Entwickler verwenden, um die Anwendung zu testen. Das spricht,
dann hast du auch nicht mehr das Phänomen, dass die Anwendung bei dir auf dem Rechner
funktioniert und beim nächsten nicht und auf deinem Produktiv-Server erst recht nicht.
So was. Dafür ist Docker eigentlich ursprünglich gedacht.
Was da heute mittlerweile draus gemacht wurde, wo Docker natürlich auch mitgeholfen hat,
weil ich meine, ihr habt den Bedarf da schon erkannt irgendwie, ist ein bisschen was anderes.
Und wo viele Leute mit Docker in Beherrung kommen, ist allerdings gar nicht mehr so bei
der ursprünglichen Sache, so nach dem Motto, wir bauen uns ein paar Test-Dinger für
schnelle Entwickler-Systeme, die wir schnell starten können und wieder wegwerfen können,
weil, wie gesagt, so ein Container starten dauert nicht länger,
wie den Befehl so zu starten. Minimal länger. Die meisten Leute kommen heutzutage mit Docker
in Berührung, wenn sie irgendwelche Anwendungen installieren, eben als Docker-Container.
Also sprich zum Beispiel Home Assistant hat einen fertigen Docker-Container. Wenn ich Home
Assistant installieren will, das ist eine Heimautomatisierungslösung, die ich verwende,
dann kann ich das einfach mit Docker machen. Und dadurch, dass die quasi dieses Docker-File
bereitstellen, starte ich bei mir einen Container, wo quasi anhand denen ihres Docker-Files dann
auch alles hochgefahren wird, so und bzw. alle Libraries dabei sind, die es braucht,
und es ist halt relativ easy für mich. Aber es hat auch ein paar Steine im Weg. Also,
wenn man jetzt, wenn man sich beispielsweise in einen Docker-Container startet, um darin quasi
nicht einfach nur eine Anwendung zu testen, die man selbst entwickelt oder irgendwas Fertiges
zu installieren, sondern noch rumbasteln muss, weil man noch gar nicht so genau weiß, wie man
das System konfigurieren muss, dass die Anwendung funktioniert, dann ist Docker sehr nervig,
weil Docker ist kein gutes Live-System. Also du kannst jetzt, du kannst zwar in einem Docker
quasi einen Init starten und hast dann da halt auch im Zweifelsfall eine Bash oder eine Shell
irgendwie drinne, aber das ist so nicht gedacht. Du musst dann quasi auch immer wieder committen,
dann musst du stoppen. Das ist eher gedacht, du hast ein Docker-File, das beschreibt, wie das
System am Ende aussehen soll, du startest es und gut ist. Auf meiner, dafür verwenden es die
meisten Leute mittlerweile. Das Schöne ist, du kannst halt auch relativ einfach Snapshots machen,
und wenn ein Upgrade in die Hose geht, kannst du relativ einfach wieder downcrate. Wobei ich finde,
das ist teilweise ein bisschen kompliziert. Wofür es sich halt gar nicht eignet ist,
wenn du quasi ein Bastelsystem haben möchtest. Also sagen wir mal, ich habe jetzt hier meinen
Linux-Server. Sag mal, warum kann ich denn hier nicht reinklicken? Immer, was ist das denn?
Läuft da irgendwas im Hintergrund? Was ist das? Wofür es sich halt gar nicht eignet ist,
wenn du ein Bastelsystem haben möchtest. Also sprich, ich habe hier jetzt meinen Server und
will jetzt darauf irgendwas ausprobieren. Und ich weiß noch gar nicht, ob ich das haben will.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, wie es funktioniert. Und ich will einfach ein bisschen rumspielen.
Das heißt, ich will ein System haben, das einfach mal da ist, auf dem ich was ausprobieren kann.
Und wenn ich es nicht mehr will, will ich es einfach rückstandslos wegwerfen können. Also
wenn du rückstandslos wegwerfen, funktioniert bei Docker, aber das live daran rumspielen
funktioniert nicht wirklich gut. Dafür gibt es dann andere Sachen. Dann hast du dann sowas
wie LXC zum Beispiel. Wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel meinen, hier habe ich bei mir
lokalen LXC-Container mit Home Assistant und Gedöns drauf. Das ist quasi ein ganz normales,
vollwertiges Linux-System, auf dem ich alles Mögliche machen kann, was ich will. Und wenn
ich nicht mehr will, kann ich ihn auch wegwerfen. Also für vollständige Bastelumgebungen ist
LXC, beziehungsweise LXD ist es eigentlich die Ubuntu-Variante, viel besser gehalten
als Docker. Docker ist wirklich nur sinnvoll Anwendung, Starten und Gutes. Aller Kehr ist
jetzt gut, übertreibt man nicht. Ich machs ja, ich machs ja, ich machs ja. Wo sind wir
stehen geblieben? Ja, aber Sino 25 Kubernetes ist für daheim vollkommen beknackt. Wo sind
wir stehen geblieben? Genau, also wir haben Nginx installiert, den brauche ich auf jeden
Fall, und jetzt habe ich mich gefragt, wie installiere ich meinen Kram drauf. Ich tendiere
dazu, dass ich auf diesen ganzen Docker-Kram und ganzen LXC-Kram auf meinem System jetzt
scheiße, weil es das einfach zu komplex macht, und mir meinen Home Assistant und, was brauche
ich sonst noch? Eigentlich nur Home Assistant und den TV-Server installiere ich mir einfach
auf der Kiste drauf. Wollen wir mal einen Benchmark machen und gucken, wie schnell die
Kiste ist? Ich meine, das ist, hat immerhin vier Kerne und ist ein Celeron mit 1,5G, kick-ass.
Wir installieren noch Sensors, dass wir gucken können, wie hieß der Kram? LM-Sensor? Wir
installieren mal Sensors und gucken mal, wie warm das Ding wird. Sensors. Okay, es ist
nicht warm. Das Ding ist passive-gekühlt, ne? Das Ding ist passive-gekühlt. So, jetzt
sieht man wieder, was praktisch an T-MAX ist. Watch Sensors. Watch führt jede Sekunde das
Kommando neu aus. Ähm, erzählen wir mal, wie warm das System wird. So, jetzt machen
wir mal irgendwie was. Komm, wir machen mal ein bisschen, wir machen mal ein bisschen
Last. Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt kein Benchmark, wir machen jetzt ein bisschen
Last. Zwo hoch, blablabla. Jetzt wollen wir mal BC ausrechnen. Bam. So, und da unten
drunter machen wir noch mal einen Top, dass wir sehen, dass das Ding auch was macht. Ein
Kern ist komplett ausgelastet. Und es wird schon ein bisschen wärmer. Okay. Starten wir
das mal dreimal, hä? Starten wir mal dreimal und gucken mal, wie warm es wird. So, drei
Kerne voll ausgelastet, was ja auch sinnvoll ist bei dreimal rechnen, ne? Wie warm? Mal
gucken, wie warm der Rechner wird. Mit was ich da so im Sommer in meinem nicht belüfteten
Abstell-Server-Raum mit rechnen kann. Komm, wisst ihr was? Wir starten noch mal ein Eats.
Oh, jetzt wird das System schon langsam unresponsive. So, jetzt lassen wir es mal kurz laufen, ich
werde hier mal kurz pinkeln.
So, Mittag am Start. Und es ist schon überhitzt und es wird gar nicht wirklich warm, ne?
Das gab es bei euch eigentlich zu Weihnachten zu essen. Also bei uns gab es Reh, Reh, so
Stückchen, Reh Gulasch, denke ich mal, also von der Konsistenz her. Reh, äh, ne, Reh,
Agu gab es, so rum, genau. Mit Rotkraut und Semmelknödel. Krass bei euch denn. Regulasch
bei Nextor, genau. Pizza, Pizza. So, also ich denke, oh, mein Prompt ist da mal und
der Rechner ist aber schon ganz schön überlastet. Deswegen mag ich den Prompt. Der ist bei Ubuntu
dabei und ist standardmäßig so konfiguriert, dass er dir alles Wichtige anzeigt. Und das
finde ich jetzt wieder das Schöne an Ubuntu-Server. Die haben irgendwie eine sinnvolle Paketauswahl
und eine sinnvolle Vorinstallation. Also kann mich da werner beschweren. Also gut, ich glaube,
das System wird nicht überhitzen. Ich greife jetzt mal kurz an den Passivkühler dran, wie
warm das Ding ist. Man kann den Finger drauf lassen, es wird ein bisschen unangenehm, aber
es ist jetzt nicht so wild. Also ich glaube, dass das Ding überhitzt, muss ich mir keine
Gedanken machen. Auch im Sommer nicht. Wie heißt das Paket? Liquid Prompt. Gibt es auch
auf GitHub? Was da? Also für andere Systeme. Kann man zig Sachen auch konfigurieren, aber
ich finde es halt einfach ganz praktisch, weil es bei Ubuntu dabei ist. Guck, das zeigt
dir auch an, was du für Prozesse im Hintergrund laufen hast. Gut. Okay, also ich würde sagen,
so viel wärmer als 66, 67 Grad oder so wird es wahrscheinlich nicht werden. Dann machen
wir mal unsere Taschenrechner wieder aus. Ja, no-skiller, immer das, wofür man braucht.
Ich bin mittlerweile auch drüber hinweg, dass ich irgendwie aus irgendwelchen ideologischen
Gründen irgendwas nehme. Also ich bin mittlerweile sogar so weit, dass wenn es die beste Technik
wäre, was es glücklicherweise nie ist, würde ich sogar Java für irgendwas nehmen. Ja, wenn
es nicht anders geht, würde ich sagen, okay, scheiß drauf, wenn es das beste für das Problem
ist, würde ich sogar was in Java machen. Aber glücklicherweise gibt es immer andere Varianten,
die besser sind. Und wenn man quasi nur eine VM hat mit 256 MB RAM und sagt, Ubuntu Server
ist mir zu fett, was der eigentlich ohne Probleme auch mit 256 MB RAM funktioniert, also absolut
ohne Probleme, weil was ist da großartig vorhin so nicht drauf, man? Nix, was im Hintergrund
läuft eigentlich, außer ein SSH. Aber wenn einem das zu viel ist, dann nimm mal irgendwas
anderes. Was nimmst du denn für deine VMs dann? Guck, und hier sieht man übrigens auch schön,
wie praktisch T-MAX ist. Hier oben was machen, unten gucken wir uns, wie warm das System wird,
unten rechts gucken wir uns die Auslastung an. Ja klar, dem werden die da auch. So, okay,
da installiere ich jetzt meinen Home Assistant auch so drauf. Kennen Sie sich gut mit Linux
und man könnte sagen, dass ich mein Geld unter anderem mit Linux verdiene. Zumindest früher
verdient habe. Wie gesagt, mittlerweile ist es mehr Richtung Softwareentwicklung, ohne selbst zu
entwickeln, sondern mir eher das durchzulesen, was andere entwickelt haben. Aber ich bin auch
schon lange dabei. Okay, Home Assistant installen, gucken wir mal, wie das funktioniert. Scheiß auf
LXC und Docker und Gedöns. Ich will Simple haben. Aber am liebsten Retard CentOS. Ja,
auf der Arbeit haben wir auch nur Retard CentOS. Das hat mir wahrscheinlich ein bisschen den Spaß
da dran verdorben. Ich kann hier gar nicht so genau sagen, warum, aber irgendwie finde ich,
vom Handling, Ubuntu macht mir einfach Spaß zu benutzen. Retard ist halt einfach nur da.
Kannst du Textinitur empfehlen? Ja, Visual Studio Code. Ach so, C, C++. Nein, C, C++ würde ich
was anderes verwenden. C, C++ würde ich den Qt Creator verwenden, den hier. Hab ich den installiert?
Ja, den würde ich verwenden. Ne, ich erstelle jetzt nichts, aber der Qt Creator ist gut.
Also der Qt Creator ist wirklich gut. Du hast so die üblichen Sachen, die man braucht. Die
Autovervollständigung ist fast so gut wie Visual Studio. Also wenn es kostenlos sein soll,
ist der Qt Creator wirklich top. Kostenlos hast du sonst auch noch, klar du kannst ja auch, es
haut dir aber ganz schön in die Tasten, der Gude. Was geht mit dem? Da kannst du natürlich auch
Visual Studio Code zu konfigurieren, dass C++ ordentlich funktioniert. Aber für C++,
das einfach was, was gut ist und funktioniert, würde ich den Qt Creator nehmen. Der ist wirklich
da taugt. Ansonsten, wenn du Geld ausgeben kannst, kannst du auch von JetBrains, Lion heißt das,
glaube ich, den ihre, habe ich aber selbst noch nicht verwendet, den ihre C++ Umgebung. Muss man
nicht für Qt zahlen, wenn man das kommerziell verwenden will. Nein, muss man nicht. Du musst
Qt, du musst dir bloß glaube ich eine kommerzielle Qt-License kaufen, wenn du es statisch linken
möchtest in, nein, Ryder ist die C Sharp IDE, Lion ist die C++ IDE. Ich glaube, du musst es bloß
in der Lizenz kaufen, wenn du es quasi mit deiner Anwendung ausliefern möchtest, sodass es quasi
embedded ist. Dann musst du eine Lizenz kaufen. Wenn du einfach nur eine Anwendung machst, die,
C Lion heißt die, genau, nicht einfach nur eine C Lion war es ja, dann kannst du mit Qt auch
kostenpflichtige Anwendungen machen. Übrigens, wo wir gerade bei Qt sind, wisst ihr worauf der EA
Origin Client passiert? Wenn ich so frage, ist eigentlich relativ klar. Das ist auch eine,
Origin ist auch eine Qt Anwendung mit Qt Web Engine, also im Prinzip ist der Origin Client
übelst das Sammelsurium. Im Prinzip ist es eine Web Anwendung, aber drumherum ist Qt mit Qt Web
Engine, was selbst wiederum ein Chrome ist, oder nicht? Plink? Nee, wie heißt es? Plink heißt es
jetzt, oder? Die Engine, ich klicke das mittlerweile zu hoch, die Dinger, die fast gleich sind,
wie die unterschiedlich heißen. Also wie gesagt, Origin ist Qt mit Qt Web Browser drinnen und ich
vermute mal, dass es die Overlay-Geschichten und so Sachen wie, ich gehe mal davon aus,
es kann auch ein FPS-Counter und sowas, sowas ist da natürlich schon native Qt und halt
wenn noch spezifische Sachen, ja. Okay, also, wo war man denn stehen geblieben? Achja, kennt ihr
das übrigens? Jetzt, Linux Hack of Doom, kennen auch die übelsten Linux-Profis manchmal nicht,
ich kannte den Trick auch noch nicht vor, also ich kenne den auch noch nicht allzu lang. Übelst
nicer Trick, und zwar, wenn man jetzt hier so sagt, hier was weiß ich, ls, und dann mache ich
History und dann sieht man ja, welche Kommandos ich ausgeführt habe. So, mal angenommen, ich will
jetzt irgendwas dawn-dawnen, was man nicht in der History sehen soll, was weiß ich. Irgendeiner will
sich, was weiß ich, Aufnahmen von seiner Lehrerin angucken, keine Ahnung, will sich das was in der
History sieht. Und normalerweise, normalerweise, der Cry, der kennt es, normalerweise wird man
dann so Sachen machen wie, ja, hier, we get super geheim, so, und danach würdest du dann quasi in
die History gehen, ne was, Bash History, würdest du in die History gehen und das quasi wieder löschen
und sowas in der Richtung. Aber, viel einfacher, man kann einfach, guck jetzt, hier ist es drinne,
man kann einfach noch geheimer, man kann einfach Leertaste davor machen und dann taucht es nicht in
der History auf. Was auch die Erklärung dafür ist, was man manchmal hat, dass man schwören könnte,
man hat ein Befehl noch ausgeführt, aber er ist nicht in der History drinne. Das ist, weil man
zufällig ein Leerzeichen davor hatte. Also es kann so und so sein. Aber das ist eine Sache,
die kennen nicht viel. Ich kannte das auch noch nicht, ich kenne das auch erst seit ein paar
Wochen, aber ich zufällig in einem Video gesehen habe. Also es gibt manchmal auch gute Videos auf
YouTube. Ansonsten sind die, sind die, sind die meisten, Linux und, und, und sonstige Videos,
die man so sieht auf YouTube, sind halt ziemlich, ja, schon ziemlich resident sleeper, weil das hast
alle schon gesehen, irgendwie gemacht. Aber das mit dem Leerzeichen davor kann ich noch nicht.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Home Assistant haben wir installiert.
Und wie gesagt, eigentlich wäre, die schuldere Variante wäre, das wirklich jetzt irgendwie mit
dem LXD oder am Docker zu machen, aber ich habe keinen Bock auf die Verwaltung drum herum. Da weiß
ich schon das nächste Mal nicht mehr, wie ich es genau eingerichtet hat. Was wird gemacht? Es
wird mein 4HE Single Point of Failure Superserver abgelöst durch drei kleine, bzw. durch drei
kleine ist zu viel gesagt, durch einen kleinen, einen MikroTik Router und einen Single Board
Computer mit Festplatte dran, weil zu overkill und zu viel Strom. Einmal auf Deutsch. Also,
ich habe aktuell einen fetten Server bei mir stehen. Den da. Moment. Den hier. Da. Die
fette Kiste. 4HE, weil 4HE Höheneinheiten. Eine HE, also das kommt nicht forehead. Genau. Also bei
so einem Rack vorne hat man hier immer so ein Ding, also so quasi hier, wo die Schrauben hinkommen,
das immer eine Höheneinheit. So und der Rechner ist quasi vier Höheneinheiten. Wenn man Racks
kauft, sieht man auch immer dann in der Beschreibung, wie viele Höheneinheiten reinpassen,
quasi 15 Höheneinheiten oder so und das ist ein ziemlich kleines Rack. Genau, drei Schrauben,
eine HE. So ist es richtig. Und das ist eine 4HE-Kiste, weil ich habe, warum es eine 4HE-Kiste ist,
ist relativ einfach. Sieht man hier, weil das Netzteil hochkant rein kommt und das Netzteil
kommt hochkant rein, weil ich einen besonders, ihr seht ja, der Raum ist nicht sonderlich groß.
Ich glaube, das kann man hier ganz gut erkennen. Der Raum ist nicht, ich stehe in der Tür. Hier ist
die Tür hier. Also hier ist die Tür. Der Raum ist nicht groß und ein normal tiefes Rack hätte
da überhaupt nicht reingepasst. Deswegen habe ich da jetzt meinen, ich glaube, 45 cm Mini-Rack
drin, da stehen 12 oder 15 Höheneinheiten und deswegen habe ich auch ein Saubergehäuse gebraucht,
was kurz ist und kurz bedeutet hoch, weil irgendwo muss das Netzteil und das Board hier rein und
Platten und alles. War gar nicht so schwer da, war gar nicht so einfach da einzufinden, so ein
passendes Gehäuse. Ja und das Ding hat halt aktuell alles drin, was irgendwie so läuft. Das
Ding macht Firewall mit PF-Sense, macht Heimautomatisierung, macht, ich habe es vorhin
gezeigt, macht irgendwie jetzt mal über Daumen gepeilt, 15 verschiedene Sachen und wenn das
System nicht mehr geht, ist scheiße, dann geht halt hier im Haus einiges nicht. Von Internet
bis Rollhähnesteuerung automatisch bis Videos angucken bis nicht mal Fernsehen, es geht nichts
im Endeffekt. Das ist bis jetzt noch kein Problem gewesen, weil das Ding relativ gut
aufgestellt ist. Ich meine, es hat kein doppeltes Netzteil drin, aber das ist ein halbwegs gutes
Be Quiet Netzteil mit absoluten Null Last richtig drauf, das geht nicht so einfach kaputt. Ja,
das hat einen ZFS-Rate, also sprich, dass eine Platte kaputt geht und hier nochmal eine Rate
1 mit den SSDs und dann hat es einen ordentlichen SAS-Controller. Also das Ding ist schon recht
ausfallssicher, da muss man sich keine Gedanken machen eigentlich, aber es ist halt trotzdem
ein bisschen Overkill, das kommt dann noch dazu. So, und deswegen wird die Kiste jetzt abgelöst
durch ein kleines 4-Kern Celeron-Board, was wir hier gerade einrichten, einen 5-Port Mikrotik-Router
für Netzwerke und Internetkram, weil der kommt immer noch Switched-RAM, das heißt 5 Ports reichen
dicker aus, 5 Ports internes Netzwerk zum Provider und zum Access-Point im Endeffekt,
ja vielleicht noch eins von der DMZ, mal gucken. Also 5 Ports reichen dicke, selbst mit 2 Providern
reichen 5 Ports dicke. Hat das Ding eine USB? Ja, eine USB hat es auch und zwar, da. Da,
da ist die USB. Das da ist die USB. Wer so eine USB ist, der weiß, auch kleine USBs
sind schwer. Darum drüber so ein billig TP-Link-Switch, das ist Unity Media Modem, eine Steckdosenleiste,
hier sieht man den, hier sieht man den 10G-Switch, da, das ist einfach nur so ein, das ist nicht
mal ein richtiges Patch-Panel, einfach so was, wo Stecker reinklipsen kann. Ja, genau und
die Kiste, die behalte ich auch, die schalte ich halt aus und verwende sie nur noch zu
Testzwecken und dann habe ich das Ganze ein bisschen entschlackt. Erstens brauchen die
3 kleinen Sachen viel, noch mal weniger Strom, der hier braucht schon nicht viel, also das
ganze Rack, das ganze Rack braucht insgesamt Eidl um die 100 Watt, bisschen weniger sogar,
man sieht es hier glaube ich am Anfang, hier, irgendwie 98 oder irgendwas steht da, also
Eidl brauchst irgendwie so, sagen wir mal so 85, 90 Watt, das klingt jetzt vielleicht
für jemanden, der sowas noch nicht betrieben hat, klingt jetzt erstmal viel, dass du quasi
irgendwie 90 Watt, 24, 7 Verbrauch hast, aber man muss sagen für ein Setup ist das nicht
viel, das ist wirklich sehr, sehr sparsam für sowas. Genau, Grosotango, das ist eigentlich
ist das nichts, das ist wirklich wenig, nicht, dass du trotz verbrauchst natürlich trotzdem,
also auch wenn es eigentlich nicht viel ist, ist es trotzdem für Rumgeeidler eigentlich
zu viel. Man muss aber dazu sagen, es ist gar nicht mal so, dass der Server das jetzt
alles verbraucht, weil im Prinzip es sind 3 10T Platten drinne, das heißt wenn die nicht
gerade sleepen, was sie zum größten Teil machen, wenn nicht gerade was passiert, verbrauchen
die auch schon mal ordentlich was. Der 10G Switch zieht auch mal was, weil der zieht
halt einfach was, da kann ich nichts dagegen machen. So ein USB braucht natürlich auch
noch ein bisschen was, wenn es durchgeht. Also sagen wir mal so, der Server ist ungefähr
für, naja sagen wir mal 2 Drittel vom Stromverbrauch verantwortlich, der Rest ist halt, naja, ja
doch, na da kommt noch Fritzbox, Unity Media, Kabelmotor, das braucht auch noch mal ein
bisschen was. Sagen wir mal so, der Server verbraucht 65% vom Strom, von dem ganzen Setup
her. Und da kann ich erstens ein bisschen was einsparen und zweitens halt mein Setup
wieder so aufstellen, dass halt nicht eine Kiste alles macht, an die ich mich gar nicht
mehr richtig traue quasi ranzugehen, weil selbst wenn ich sie einfach nur neu starte
nach einem Update, in der Zwischenzeit der Fernseh nicht geht. Also es ist halt, es ist
zwar technisch irgendwie ganz cool, ja, aber auf ein Kill. Ja. Das ist so ein Blood Pack,
ich sag ja, es ist nichts eigentlich für ein ordentliches Setup, gar nichts, es ist
nicht viel. Kenne mich da nicht so aus, aber wieso brauchst du das für Internet und so
was, einfach hobbymäßig hat man irgendwelche Vorteile. Naja, irgendwo muss man den Kram
ja laufen lassen. Irgendwo muss man seinen Kram ja laufen lassen. Man hat die Möglichkeit
sagen wir mal viel Cloud technisch zu machen, wenn man das nicht Self-hosted laufen lassen
will, wenn du allerdings Sachen halt daheim laufen lassen möchtest und nicht in irgendeiner
Cloud. Irgendwo müssen die Dinger ja drauf laufen. Irgendwo muss es ja laufen, da kommst
ja nicht drum herum, ja. Und bei mir läuft es halt auf der Kiste. Ja, gut, so jetzt haben
wir die Home Assistant installiert. Ja, was wir heute einrichten gerade ist die Kiste,
die quasi den Heimautomatisierungs- und Fernsehteil von meiner 4HE Superserver Single Point of
Failure Kiste. Warum Fernseh nicht läuft, weil Fernseh quasi, stell dir die Dose vor
von Unity Media, die da aus der Wand kommt. Man sieht sie hier im Video sogar irgendwo.
Da, hier, guck mal, da ist die Unity Media Dose, dahinter. Ich zoome da jetzt nicht hin,
aber hier. Da kommt Unity Media raus. Mehrfach kommt der Unity Media raus. Dann geht Unity
Media an eine TV-Karte. Die TV-Karte, da sieht man erstmal, wie komplex das Setup eigentlich
ist, ja. Also ein Setup, was quasi von der Architektur erschönt ist, muss nicht einfach
sein und vor allem nicht einfach in der Handhabung her. Also das Kabel geht raus in eine TV-Karte.
Die TV-Karte steckt in dieser 4HE Kiste drinnen. Die TV-Karte selbst ist in einem Container
eingebunden, wo, den LXC-Container, wo TV-Headend draufläuft. TV-Headend macht quasi Timeshift,
Aufnahmen, Live-TV und sonst was, ja. Und drüben im Wohnzimmer oder auch hier auf der
Kiste haben wir, drüben im Wohnzimmer habe ich ein Nvidia Shield-TV stehen, da läuft
Kodi drauf und Kodi als Oberfläche halt auf dem Fernseher verbindet sich zu diesem TV-Headend-Server,
der dann quasi das Fernsehprogramm streamt. Was eigentlich ganz praktisch ist, weil so
hast du keine Probleme mit, ähm, welches Gerät was guckt. Es ist quasi ab dem TV-Headend
ist alles Netzwerk-Stream. Also sprich, es könnten 15 Leute im Haus, die es nicht gibt,
aber könnten, keine Ahnung, 15 Leute im Haus, bis das Netzwerk zusammenbricht, den gleichen
Fernsehserner gucken. Das ist vollkommen egal. Und das Ding macht halt auch Aufnahmen, weil
es dann eh an ist, 24-7. Und deswegen geht Fernseh nicht, weil Fernseh auch darüber
geht. Ja, der Rollerhand geht, also der Rollerhand geht noch. Also der Rollerhand mit Kurbel
geht natürlich eh, ganz logisch, mit Gurt. Der geht natürlich eh, weil den Gurt kann
ich noch nicht fernsteuern. Aber die Rollen, die automatisch funktionieren, die gehen auch
noch mit dem Knopf, der da ist, aber was nicht mehr funktioniert ist, dass die Rollen automatisch
morgens hoch und abends runtergehen. Weil ich das über Home Assistant gelöst habe
und Home Assistant läuft, wer hätte das gedacht, auf dem System mit. Smart Home Basis Station,
genau, genau. Home Assistant ist eine Heimautomatisierungssoftware, die quasi ganz viele verschiedene Hersteller
miteinander verbinden kann, sodass man nicht auf einen Hersteller festgelegt ist. Welche
Linux-Distribution nutzt du hier? Du meinst jetzt auf dem System oder die VM, die ich hier
habe? Also meinst du das, was wir hier auf dem Server laufen haben oder Desktop? VM,
das ist Manjaro mit i3. Manjaro. Manjaro mit i3 mit Knorm-Terminal und im TMAX drin und
ein bisschen halt Custom-Farben und Gedulds angepasst. So, jetzt haben wir Home Assistant
install. Ja, Gozo, man kann immer noch, man kann es immer noch mehr übertreiben. Oh,
was ich letztens gesehen habe, sehr nice, was ich bei uns entweder in Flur und in Hof
oder nur in Hof und nur in Flur einbauen will, habe ich letztens in einem Video gesehen.
Muss ich gerade mal kurz raussuchen in der Historie auf dem zweiten Rechner. Und zwar
eine LED-Beleuchtung für außen und zwar eine ordentlich helle LED, ordentlich helle LED-Beleuchtung
für draußen. Ja, hier in dem Video hat er tut das gezeigt. Das da, genau, ja, sowas
wie LED-Strahler, so Deckenbeleuchtung halt, oder Terrassenbeleuchtung oder halt so Dinger,
die man quasi in so, wenn man da schon so eine Einbuchtung hat, die man so reinmachen
kann. Steht hier irgendwie, wie hell das ist. Nee, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ganz nice.
Kannst nämlich auch mit Home Assistant steuern. Kannst nämlich auch mit Home Assistant steuern
und die Dinger sind halt schön hell und man kann die Farben anpassen, so wie es gerade
nett ist. Da zeigt das am Ende auch ein bisschen, wie er das in seinem Haus gemacht hat. Gut,
das ist seine, ja hier, da sieht man die Dinger. Das sind die Teile. Und die sind schon ordentlich
hell. Das ist schon ganz nice. Der Typ hat es eh komplett übertrieben mit seinem Haus.
Wer sich für Heimautomatisierungen interessiert, kann sich die Videos von ihm angucken. Die
sind schon ganz cool. Aber der hat es halt voll übertrieben mit seinem Haus. Guckt euch
das mal, ey. Der hat es halt voll massiv übertrieben. Sogar die Zuckerstangen gehen LED beleuchtet
an und aus. Der hat es halt massiv übertrieben, der Typ. Wenn der da drin CSGO spielt, ist
alles Instant-Header, ey. Bei so viel RGB-Beleuchtung. Und wenn er dann noch den Gaming-Handschuh
anhat, den wir uns letztens angeschaut haben, dann ist es vorbei. Alter, guckt euch das
mal an. Das ist halt übelst nice. Ich habe es letztens schonmal im Video gezeigt, aber
weil ich es so geil finde, zeige ich es nochmal allen, die es nicht gesehen haben von ihm.
Der hat auch ein Video, also könnt ihr ja mal gucken bei ihm hier, das ist The Hook Up
auf YouTube. Der macht relativ viele Heimautomatisierungs-Videos. Der hat ein Video gezeigt von seiner kompletten
Hausbeleuchtung, die er über Home Assistant steuert. Hier siehst du, hier kannst du auch
die LEDs und so einstellen. Ja, das ist die Oberfläche, die ich auch verwende. Nicht
mit so viel RGB-Beleuchtung. Und der hat es halt echt, wenn man sich das hier anguckt,
der hat es halt komplett übertrieben mit RGB-Beleuchtung. Und der hat ein anderes Video, wo er zeigt,
was er für Netzteile hat. Da hat sich irgendwie erstmal, ich bin mir nicht mehr genau sicher
welches, aber da hat sich erstmal 3.200 Watt Server-Netzteile geholt, dass er, nicht Server-Netzteile,
3.200 Watt Netzteile geholt, dass das überhaupt zuverlässig alles läuft mit RGB-Beleuchtung.
Bam! Aber man muss sagen, geil ist es schon, ne? Vor allem, wenn die ein bisschen abgedreht
sind, dann kann man am Ende kommen und so. Weil nice ist es schon, das ist schon nice.
Du kannst das ja programmieren, wie du willst. Der hat auch richtig coole Sachen. Der hat
so ein Halloween-Ding, das habe ich das letzte Mal schon nicht gefunden. Da erscheinen die
LEDs so wie Augen im Dunkeln und so. Auch übelst geil. Das ist schon cool. Also ich
finde das echt sehr nice, was der da gebaut hat. Stromrechnung will man sich damit wahrscheinlich
nicht wirklich angucken. Der Kerl da verbraucht wahrscheinlich um Weihnachten und Halloween
bei dem so viel rum wie das restliche Jahr. Aber guck mal, das ist doch geil, oder? Wieso
die Augen aufploppen und wieder einfaden und so. Das ist doch cool. Es ist voll kreativ,
die Idee auch da drauf zu kommen, ne? Die LEDs brauchen nicht so viel. Allerdings,
was weiß ich, 15.000 LEDs oder wie viel auch immer der da hat, ich habe keine Ahnung,
die brauchen halt schon wieder ein bisschen was, ne? Der zeigt das irgendwo in dem Video
auf was er sich hier gekauft hat an Netzteilen. Okay, ich finde es nicht mehr, aber der hat
irgendwo die Netzteile gezeigt, die er hat und das sind echt fette, fette Dinger. Ja,
es zieht auch schon ein bisschen was. Hier, da hat er das Netzteil. Ach, doch keine 1200,
durch Mist erzählt. Da hat er irgendwie ein paar Stück am Start. Also, das frisst schon
ordentlich. Und das braucht ein bisschen was. So, install, bla bla bla. So, und jetzt starten
wir das mal. Gucken, ob es läuft. Und dann gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, wann es läuft.
Ne, Energieeffizienz sind Dinger wirklich nicht. Ich habe letztens auch ein paar LEDs
gegrillt, ausversehen. Ich habe mit so einem Steckbord und einem Raspberry ein bisschen
rumgebastelt, habe den falschen Widerstand reingemacht und dann haben die LEDs auf einmal
nichts mehr gemacht und das Kabel danach ist das Plastik weggeschmolzen und da habe ich
gesagt, Alter, was stinkt denn hier so? Hab ich dann festgestellt, es war der falsche
Widerstand. Habe ich ein bisschen was kaputt gemacht. Aber das waren nur so kleine Bastelzeuge,
sind nicht viel kaputt gegangen. Also, die kosten ja nicht die Welt jetzt. So ein Set,
so ein Teileset mit Kabel kostet irgendwie 20 Euro oder so, wo man, da sind halt viel
mehr drin, als die, die ich kaputt gemacht habe. Da ist ein kompletter Satz an LEDs und
Steckbords und Widerstände und Kabel und so ist da massig drin. Da ist ja noch genug
übrig. Kann man ab und zu ein bisschen was kaputt machen. So, ist das jetzt gestartet
mittlerweile mal. Ja, da läuft es. Ich darf wieder nicht reinklicken. Ja, sage mal. Jetzt
geht's. Da ist mein Exklusiv-Mode aus. Mal gucken, was da ist. Bis dann, gozo, dango.
Ich muss mal gucken, es gibt bei mir auch demnächst Weihnachtsfutterstalls noch. Ich muss mal
kurz nachgucken, wann es das gibt. Warte mal, ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, wieder am Start. Also bis 18 Uhr habe ich noch Zeit. Gut, dann schauen wir doch
mal, ob das Home Assistant Zeug läuft. Ja, wunderbar. Passwort, Admin, Passwort 123456.
Ach nee, Admin. Super, Special Passwort. Das werde ich eher nachher noch alles ändern.
Also nie. Ihr kennt mich ja. Was genau soll das sein? Hat er irgendwie meinen Schiel-TV
discovert oder sowas? Kann das sein? Android.local. Ja, das wird mein Schiel-TV sein, denke ich
mal. Was er da discovert hat. Was der alles macht. Yes. Ok, Home Assistant funktioniert.
Das ist schon mal schön. Passwort liegt ja. Ganz furchtbar. Komplexes, hoch, wahnsinnig
secures Passwort. So, blablabla. Ja, bist du jetzt. Configure Autostart. Ja, das wollen
wir machen. Was ist denn eigentlich für eine Home Assistant Version dabei? Falls überhaupt
eine dabei ist. Nee, die Instinten bringen, liefern gar keine mit, was ja auch sinnvoll
ist. Braucht kein Mensch mitgeliefert und die mitgelieferte Variante wird eh keiner verwenden.
Wobei ich das eigentlich gar nicht als Root laufen lassen will, fällt mir da gerade auf.
Vielleicht installieren wir das noch mal. Und zwar als nicht Root. Weil im Heimatverzeichnis
Vermut ist schon irgendwie beknackt. Da war ein extra User für. Kennst du eigentlich
die Turnkey-Niedungs-LXC? Ja, kenne ich. Wie deaktiviert man denn an Pairsten-HA-Dings.
Verwerbe das nie richtig verwendet. Deaktiviert. Easy. Easy. Oh, die Musik ist aus. Ist die
Musik aus. Das geht immer. Zellermusik ist beste.
Okay, Home Assistant haben wir jetzt installiert. Und wir deinstallieren es gleich wieder. Das
hat es voll gebracht. Das hat es voll gebracht. Und jetzt fügen wir einen neuen User hinzu.
Und zwar einen HA-User. Junix-Passwort. Yes, natürlich ist die Information korrekt. So
und jetzt Quiz-Frage. Es gibt ein 0,1 Cent G2A-Gutschein zu gewinnen. Was ist der Unterschied
zwischen Su-User, also Su-HA oder Su-HA? Quiz-Frage. Eis-Käuter, das wird ein Teil
meiner Ablösung für meinen super fetten 4-HA-Singlepoint-of-Failure-Super-Server. Er wird hier aufgesplittet in einen kleinen
Vierkern-Zelleron-Kiste, einen Mikrotik-Router und einen Mininas. Ja, das ist im Prinzip
schon so... Alles ist nicht so falsch, was ihr schreibt. Das stimmt auch alles, aber
das ist nicht der Unterschied. Was macht denn das Minus? Also ich werde es euch jetzt einfach
erzählen. Das Minus führt die Logging-Skripte aus und das ohne Minus nicht. Deswegen habe
ich auch, wenn ich mich mit Minus einlogge und environment-gucke, nämlich das was Steinex
gerade geschrieben hat, ist dann auch so, dann sind die ganzen Environments gesetzt wie
wenn ich dieser User wäre. Ohne Minus ist zu Minus in der Regel das was man will. Alternativ
gibt es dann auch so etwas wie sudo-u-ha-i und so etwas in der Richtung macht glaube
ich genau das gleiche. Minus i ist interactive-logging und ohne Minus i muss ein Programm ausgeben,
was es macht und dann nicht, aber ich kürze und knarre hier. Haha, Sepharo. Näh, Berufsschule
ist der größte Crap überhaupt, das würde ich nicht machen. Also erstens würden mir
nach dem ersten Tag schon mal alle Schüler massiv auf den Sack gehen. Dann zu würden
mir wahrscheinlich alle meine Kollegen auf den Sack gehen und das komplette System und
ihr HK auf den Sack gehen. Also warum sollte ich jemals Berufsschullehrer machen? Näh,
näh, näh, näh, näh. Berufsschule ist das Sinnloseste überhaupt. Was meint ihr? Irgendjemand
der absolut keine Ahnung hat von dem Beruf und sich hinsetzt, also mal angenommen ihr
nehmt jetzt, nehmt mal den Friseur zum Beispiel, nehmt mal den Fabian als Beispiel und dann
nehmt mal den Sepharo, wenn wir jetzt die zwei nehmen würden und der Sepharo geht arbeiten,
er geht in die Berufsschule und der Fabian wird sich hinsetzen und quasi ein halbes Jahr
lang IHK Prüfungen lernen, also quasi ein halbes Jahr, bevor das Sepharo Abschlussarbeit
schreiben müsste, wird der Fabian hinsetzen und Abschlussprüfungen lernen. Also sprich,
du hast einen, der sich auskennt und du hast einen anderen, der eigentlich keine Ahnung
hat, aber dreißig ein halbes Jahr lang IHK Abschlussprüfungen geübt hat. Was meint
ihr, wer wird die bessere Prüfung schreiben? Oder sagen wir mal so, packen würden's beide,
ja, packen würden's beide und ich gehe davon aus, dass der Fabian die bessere Prüfung
hätte, weil die IHK Prüfungen komplett für'n Arsch sind. Wir können uns mal irgendwann,
das machen wir, wir gucken uns wirklich mal, da muss mir aber einer von euch den Link schicken,
weil nicht, dass mir irgendjemand vorwerfen kann, ich hätte da irgendwas gepiratet oder
so, ne paar IHK Prüfungen im Stream angucken, das machen wir, das schreib ich mir auf.
Ja, in der Berufsschule bringen sich gar nichts.
Also, ich finde, die Berufsschule ist so sinnlos gewesen. Ich meine, ich fand's gut.
Weil man sich komplett, das war im Prinzip wie Urlaub, Berufsschule, ja. Berufsschule
war echt wie Urlaub. Ich hab einfach nur da gesessen und gerade in die Löcherluft geguckt,
im Endeffekt. Und du musst nach der Berufsschule auch nicht mehr auf die Arbeit, was natürlich
noch viel geiler ist. Habe vor einiger Zeit die IHK Abschlussprüfung
gemacht, fand ich die Fragen absolut dumm und zum Teil mehrdeutig. Ja, sind sie auch.
Ja, machen wir Sebaros. Wenn wir die dann im Stream zeigen dürfen, dann gucken wir uns
Sebaros, Sebaros Abschlussarbeit an oder Sebaros Zwischenprüfung oder so. Dann sehen wir mal,
wie dumm die IHK Prüfungen sind. Richtig dumm, ja. An den Vereinen muss ich jetzt
auch einmal im Jahr 50 Euro Gebühren bezahlen, ne? Einfach so muss jeder, muss jeder, der
in der Firma gründet oder den Antrag ausfüllt, da hast du klein gelitten, musst IHK Gebühren
bezahlen. Bam. Ich meine, 50 Euro im Jahr sind nicht viel, aber ich weiß dann überhaupt
nicht, wofür ich das eigentlich bezahlen soll. Ich hab mit denen noch nie was zu tun. Also
in meiner Ausbildung, aber mit der Firma nicht. Außer, dass die mir abends so Briefe schicken
und so eine komische IHK-Rundschau oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, wofür ich die 50 Euro bezahle.
100 Euro, boah. Nice Sebaros. Okay, Home Assistant funktioniert. Auch als
eigener User, so muss das sein. So, was brauchen wir denn als Nächstes? Nein, Sammabrauch auf
der Kiste garantiert nicht. Ähm. Jetzt wieder Rundfunk weiter, ja, so ungefähr. Home Assistant
X haben wir drauf. Antivir hätten wir noch. Für Fernsehkram. Mal gucken, welche Version
dabei ist. Wie, die liefern gar keins mehr mit? Lul. Lul. Na gut. Dann installieren wir
es halt aus denen, ihren Repos. Sonst hätt ich halt das Offizielle genommen, weil warum
nicht? Offizielle Pakete sind in der Regel immer besser. Was Updates und so anbelangt,
aber naja. Dann installieren wir es halt aus den näheren Repos. So, was brauch ich denn
noch? Ich brauch mein Home Assistant drauf. Ich muss jetzt noch mal auf meinen anderen
Server gucken, was ich da aktuell drauf laufen hab. Äh, 1.60. Müssen wir gucken, was da
für Docker-Gestellens läuft. Ich Hardhop. Äh, Docker-Gedöns läuft da drauf. Da läuft,
was hab ich denn da für Docker-Geschiss drauf laufen? Organizer? Ja, das brauchen wir
unbedingt. Äh, und der Rest ist Home-Assistent-Gedöns. So, und auf meinem, auf der anderen Kiste,
auf der anderen Kiste läuft, achso, erst mal root werden, ja, ist gut. So, Nextcloud läuft
im Internet, sondern nicht auf der Kiste, wo wir jetzt drauf sind. Ähm, Summer und
Docker-Gedöns kommt auf das NAS, das kommt da auch nicht drauf. Das P-Hole könnten wir
noch drauf machen. Das wollte ich wieder ausprobieren. Das P-Hole wollte ich mal jetzt ausprobieren
wieder. Das, das P-Hole, das hört sich, das hört sich echt pervers an, oder? Den P-Hole
wollte ich mal wieder ausprobieren. Ähm, weil letztens hatten wir das ja im Stream
von, dass es angeblich nicht mal das Problem gibt, dass die, dass die Browser dadurch
hängen bleiben. Das probieren wir doch mal aus. Das installieren, das installieren wir
uns doch jetzt dazu. Nextcloud kommt intern, Mail-Backup kommt auch intern, Fritzbox, äh,
Fritzbox-Kontakt, das Sync kommt noch drauf und TV-Headernt, gut. Also, brauchen wir jetzt
müssen wir einen P-Hole installieren und einen TV-Headernt noch und dann haben wir zum größten
Teil alles. Siehste, und das meine ich ja, im Prinzip ist das Setup ja relativ simpel.
Da brauchen wir kein LXC und kein Docker und kein sonst was, einfach die drei Dienste
auf das System geknallt und gut ist. Gerade erst dazu gekommen, was geht's heute? Ähm,
ich hab doch meinen 4HE Super, äh, Superserver, der alles macht bei mir im Haus noch rumstehen
und ich will den jetzt ablösen durch drei kleinere Sachen, nämlich einen MikroTik-Router,
ne, ne, Stromsparendes, Vierkern-Zeleron-Board und ähm, Mini-NAS. Braucht weniger Strom und
ist nicht mehr so anfällig. Das ist ein Teil davon, das ist hier die Zeleron-Kiste. Vier
Kern für Heim-Automatisierung und sonst was. So, ich bin vergesslich. Also, was? Genau,
die V-Header müssen wir installieren und ein P-Horn. Ubuntu, was viel toller ist, ähm,
in YouTube-Videos, wenn da irgendwie einer Ubuntu installiert, dann sagt er nicht Ubuntu,
sondern die coolen Leute sagen immer, Ubuntu, Ubuntu. Und wenn man sich überlegt, das kommt
ja irgendwie aus Südafrika oder so, man spricht es unter Garantie. Ich kann kein Südafrika,
was, was, was spreche ich in Südafrika Französisch? Keine Ahnung, äh, es, es ist, bin ich mir
so sicher, dass es dort auf jeden Fall Ubuntu heißt und nicht Ubuntu. Garantiert nicht.
Install, install für, für Ubuntu hätt ich das gerne. Ah, wie, ist das die einzige Install-Variante,
irgendwie komisch Nilster oder nach Basch zu, nach Basch zu pipen oder was? Na, ich weiß
ja nicht. Hat er kein Repo oder so? Ich will mir, ich will mir das Install-Script eigentlich
gar nicht durchlesen, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ich will einfach ein Repo haben. Wir haben
keine Repo, oder? Oder? Ubuntu. Ja, das klingt auch viel afrikanischer.
Ja, ja, die wollen den Installer anzeigen. Ja, die machen das wirklich alle über diesen
komischen, über diesen komischen Installer-Script. Hä? Ich bin kein Fan von irgendwelchen Installer-Scripts
nach Basch pipen, alles gut. Das ist eigentlich so, nicht so the way. The way ist das. Wobei
das ist out, das ist ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so. Auch ein Docker-Container. Wir haben
uns ja explizit dafür entschieden, nicht zu Docker-Containern auf der Kiste. 20? Was
machst du mit 20 Raspberries? Also ich komme aktuell nur auf, halt mal im Keller den, den
anderen, den, den, den, äh, für Gegensprech-Dings, Stells, und den haben, eigentlich, ich komme
auf drei Raspberry-Zeros und einen Raspberry-Drei, der aber eigentlich nur noch läuft und nichts
macht. Die, die im Betrieb sind. Ich habe zwar hier auch noch ein paar rumliegen, aber
20? 20 ist hart. Was, was machst du mit den 20?
Okay, wir, wir copy-pasten einfach die Repos von denen. Sudo brauchen wir also gut, garantiert
nicht. Okay, UPDATE. Und dann gucken wir, ob es einen TV her dann gibt. Also wenn du
nicht weißt, was du mit einem Raspberry-Pie machen sollst, es gibt so ein paar Dinger,
wie gesagt, von denen ich denke, das ist nicht schlecht. Falls Piehole mittlerweile was taugt,
taugt es das auch zu einer Sache. Das erste ist, sich mal mit Linux auseinanderzusetzen.
Dafür ist es wirklich praktisch. Vor allem halt mal mit einem Linux, was nicht in der
VM ist, weil man da schon potentiell ein paar andere Probleme haben kann, so nach dem Motto,
was macht man, wenn das Ding jetzt im Reboot hängt oder so, was du bei der VM nicht hast.
Du schatzt einfach neu und siehst halt trotzdem. Und das nächste sind irgendwelche Heimautomatisierungsgeschichten.
Achso, ja. Vor Heimautomatisierungsansehen ist es auch praktisch. Und das nächste ist,
es mit irgendwelchen Addons zu versehen. Zum Beispiel einem Automation-Head, wo du dann
irgendwelche Geräte mit messen kannst oder über die GPIO-Pins schalten kannst, Luftfeuchtigkeitswasser
oder Temperaturmesser. Aber gut, das ist eher was im Rahmen, wenn man sich für Heimautomatisierungen
insgesamt installiert. Die Musik ist übelst leise auf einmal. Ja.
Aber ansonsten, ich mein, wenn man da jetzt nicht den konkreten Anwendungsfall hat oder
so, dann einfach nur für irgendwas, was so pauschal sinnvoll ist, weiß ich nicht. Da
gibt's eigentlich nix. Oh, jetzt ist es auf einmal wieder laut. Jetzt wieder nicht. Nintendo
weiß nicht, was sie wollen. Laut oder leise. Sah Zelda in Breath of the Wild so aus? Nee,
das ist eher, das ist eher so die, die, keine Ahnung, die, keine Ahnung, welche Zelda-Reinkarnation
das sein soll. Das ist die Weep-Zelda. Ja, Telekom kommt bei mir auch weg. Sobald ich
Unity Media umgestellt hab und mein IPv4 noch ordentlich funktioniert, wie sie es versprochen
haben, kommt die Telekom, sobald ich kündigen kann, weg. Also ich glaub, ich kann im Juni
oder so keine Telekom kündigen. Bäm. Weg. Weggeklatscht. Telekom. Das Einzige, was ich
noch machen muss, ist die Rufnummer portieren. Die portier ich zu so einem 2,50 Euro VoIP-Provider
und dann ist es gut. Okay, wir wollten jetzt noch P-Holz. Nee, nee, TV hat alles. Moment.
Ist das blöd? Ach, Moment, ich hab ja nur den Key geadded, ich habe das Repo noch gar
nicht geadded. Wo steht denn das Repo hier zum Adden? Hier. Stable, unstable, nee, nee,
nee. Was machen die denn da? Das da brauchen wir doch, den Rest brauchen wir nicht. Was
machen die denn da? Sudo? Ach so, die führen das einfach aus. Das da brauchen wir nur,
das ist alles. Was für eine TV-Karte benutzt du eigentlich? Das ist eine, ich sag's dir.
Ich muss noch mal kurz rumfahren mit dem Stuhl. Das ist eine WinTV Quad HD von Hauptauge,
die gar nicht Hauptauge heißen, sondern irgendwie Happasch oder so. Die hatten ja mal eine Zeit
lang, bevor Elgato auf die Idee kam, einfach deutlich bessere Hardware zu produzieren,
waren die mal relativ im Trend für Konsolen-Capture-Karten. Und die haben dann irgendwie den Anschluss
verpasst. Jetzt kann man es installieren. Fernsehen gibt's noch, ja. Ich weiß auch
nicht, warum man euch wie gesagt nicht gucken kann auf dem Fernseher. Admin. Admin ist Radar-Passwort,
haha. Unser bester Lieblings-Passwort. Warum ist die Zelda-Musik auf einmal so Jazz-Style-mäßig?
Da gefällt mir die klassische Sache vom 20. Jubiläum aber besser. Was ist denn TV-Hat
und das ist ein TV-Server. Damit kannst du Fernseh aufnehmen, Fernseh streamen, nicht
nur Fernseh, also nicht nur Kabel. Kannst damit alles, PTV, Satellit, Unity Media, ja,
unter dem Haus verteilen per Netzwerk. Passive-Exile, geiles Game, übelst geiles Game, hab ich
viele Stunden mit dem Fabian gespielt, schon als es neu war noch, als Beta war noch, aber
übelst geil. Passive-Exile ist auch der Grund, warum alle anderen Action-Haggons-Lay-Dinger
abstinken, ja. Das sind einfach die guten Diablo-Leute von Blizzard, die haben sich
gedacht, scheiß drauf, wir machen Passive-Exile. Okay, wir sind jetzt mal mutig, wir pipen
jetzt einfach, wir pipen jetzt einfach das nach und nach Bash, easy. Oh, ist also genauso
wie man es nicht macht. Okay, es läuft auch. What? Command-Bash-Not-Found. Äh, natürlich,
was denn sonst? Null. Jetzt geht's. Ich finde es schon mal interessant, dass ich erst mal
ein Raspberry-Logo kriege. Das schafft Vertrauen in das Package. Was ist denn das für ein geiles
Terminal? Das, das ist Gnome-Terminal. Ganz normales Gnome-Terminal. Moment, ich will
mein Device nicht transformen, ich will einfach es darauf installieren. Geh mal weg, abbrechen.
Kann man das abbrechen irgendwie? Ich will es einfach zusätzlich installieren zu allem
anderen auch, oder? Ist das, ist das, äh, oder darf man das nicht? Sollte klappen. Wir
werden es ja sehen, wenn nicht muss ich nochmal neu installieren. Äh, hallo? Ah, wenn man
okay, wenn man okay, äh, Escape drückt, dann... Ich bin mir da jetzt nicht sicher, ob man
das... Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das einfach drauf installieren sollte. Japanischer Gesang, ja.
Oder, äh, Zockertem, was willst du noch wissen? Also, wie gesagt, das Terminal ist Gnome-Terminal,
ich kann ja, aber wenn du noch was wissen willst, steh's los. Ich hab Schiss, dass das
mein System irgendwie... Alter, was ist das Problem? Transformt in ein P-Hole, was ich,
äh, so gar nicht haben will. Vielleicht muss ich doch einen P-Hole, LXC-Container oder
so was halt drauf hauen. Oh, wenn ich da jetzt nicht so scharf drauf bin, ehrlich gesagt.
Das klappt jetzt, aber wenn du das sagst... Ich weiß nicht, debatet wert. Ehe, falsch
die Mode. So, it needs static IP. Bleib mal bei DHCP, ich... Du kriegst schon eine feste
Release, mach dir mal keine Gedanken. Select Upstream DNS Provider. Äh, wo ist denn Cloudflare
da? Cloudflare oder Google? Cloudflare, ha? Ja, 1111 ist Cloudflare. Cloudflare ist ja
der neue Shit. Select any list. Alles. Bam. Protogolls. Äh, ja, kann ich leider zur Zeit
nicht mit, äh... Gibt's bei mir noch nicht. Obwohl, ich kann's ja mal einschalten, schadet
ja nix, ne? Do you want to use... No! Äh, ich will... Ich will die DHCP behalten! Meinen
Sie an und unten rechts und den Sensor... Achso, das ist TMAX. TMAX und einfach ein
paar Splits mit... Also hier unten läuft, ähm, Watch Sensors und hier neben läuft
ein Hardtop. Und das ist TMAX. Dieses Ding, mit dem ich die Fenster gesplittet hab. Ich
werde das Gefühl nicht los, dass ich Peerhole nicht installieren sollte, wenn ich will,
dass mein Server normal bleibt. Probieren wir's mal, ich kann den mal neu installieren.
Overwatch alter Team spielt Paladins. Weil der High-Rest so viel geiler ist, ne? Das ist
die Dekeron-Song, äh. Ne, ne, ne, ich installiere hier kein Peerhole drauf. Oh man, das hat
die IP schon gesetzt, oder was? Weil, ähm... Das ist mir zu... Inversiv. Ich... Ich glaube,
ich mach da doch einen LXC-Container drauf und dass da Peerhole drauflaufen. Alter, was
ist mit der Musik los? Was geht mit denen ab? Das ist... Soll das die Garonenmusik sein?
Das hört schon ein bisschen beknackt an. Komm, scheiß drauf, Yolo, wir installieren
jetzt den Peerhole drauf und gucken, was passiert. Für so was, für solche Test-Dinger, dafür
ist ein LXC-Container wirklich sehr praktisch. Dafür ist ein LXC-Container praktisch. Aber
egal, muss ich den Sommer noch mal neu installieren, wenn ich Pech hab, bam. Die... Die... Also
diese Zelda 30 Jahre-Kompilation ist mir viel zu Jazz-Style-mäßig, die gefällt mir nicht.
Nein, ich will kein LXC-Container, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will kein
LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein,
ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur
ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein,
ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein
LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein,
ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur
ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein, ich will nur ein LXC-Container. Nein,
Vielen Dank für's Zuhören!